(Joey slurping)
- Mm, very good stuff.
- Clearly didn't put any.
(Joey clicking teeth)
- I didn't expect how
bitter that was gonna be.
- It's just black coffee.
- Beans.
- The beans.
(relaxing music)
- You know, I didn't
know what an Americano is
until I moved to Japan.
- You thought it was
watered down coffee?
- Yeah,
watered down coffee.
Yeah because, do you know,
I only started caring about
coffee after I moved to Japan
because before I moved to Japan
it was so easy to get
reasonable coffee, right?
And I was like,
"Why is the Japan coffee
like, so watered down?"
And then it's 'cause everything here
is like Americano, it's just
watered down espressos.
- Yeah, it's like
Americano standard of coffee.
Is this the cold open?
- Yeah, I guess so.
- Welcome to this
episode of "Trash Taste."
- Hey, you're not the host.
(speakers laughing)
- Happy New Year, boys and girls.
Welcome back to another episode of-
- Well hopefully it's happy New Years.
Happy New Year for us,
but maybe for you,
it is New Years Eve.
- Happy New Years Eve,
if you're in America.
If you're in Japan or around that area,
then happy New Year, welcome to 2022.
I'm Joey, and I'm with
Garnt and Connor as always.
And it's the new year, new me.
(Garnt laughing)
- You look like you were just like,
serving tables, I just realized.
(speakers laughing)
- I'm here to serve you some
content ladies and gentlemen.
- [Connor] Joey just
finished his part-time job
serving some tables.
- Just quickly ran down, you know,
YouTube's been tough in 2021,
almost got my channel canceled, sorry.
- I got to ask, did you cut your hair
because you were just like,
"Oh, it's a new year in the podcast.
New year, new me?"
- No, that's totally
coincidental actually.
I was like, "Oh yeah, this
episode is gonna be New Years,
and I'll look completely different."
No, I was just like,
I wanted to get a haircut anyway,
because I was, oh, I
am still at the point.
I don't know if I actually
went back to Australia,
but I figured if I'm gonna see my parents
for the first time in two years,
maybe get rid of the Jesus hair, you know?
Get a fresh cut.
- So, last week I believe
we commented on the country,
thankfully, opening back up,
and that's going to be very dated now,
because as we're filming this episode,
the country's closed back down.
So by the time this episode comes out,
we don't know where
the country's gonna be.
You know, maybe it's gonna be open,
maybe it's gonna be closed, I don't know.
- Ladies and gentlemen, the Omicron.
- Let's just stoop
commenting on current events.
- Yeah.
- That's probably good.
- Let's just stop doing that.
- Then Mr. B screwed, I'm kidding.
(speakers laughing)
- Yeah so,
yeah, like literally as of
yesterday of us recording,
Japan announced that they're
gonna shut down the country again,
which is honestly like, I give them props
that they acted so goddamn quickly.
Like, this new prime minister
is not fucking around.
- Hold up, hold up,
let's pretend,
(Connor laughing)
if this was something else, right?
Like, this was something that
Japan wasn't eager to do,
this would have taken months.
They were like, "Oh we can,
we have an excuse to close borders?
Oh shit, yeah, well close them."
- Well, they didn't do that
with the Olympics, did they?
- Oh, well, I mean, you know,
it depends.
- I think that
when I saw online that the
prime minister was like,
I think it was like two days prior
that the new strain had
been announced, right?
And then everyone on
Twitter was like, oh shit,
it only took the government
two days to act upon this.
And I'm like-
- Oh no, they decided-
- Why is this like,
a rare event?
Shouldn't that be normal.
- They decided the moment on,
they just took them
two days to approve it,
and then some.
- [Joey] Yeah.
(speakers laughing)
- They knew what they were doing.
- Yeah.
- But anyway, current events, bad.
- [Joey] Current event's
bad.
- Sad.
New year, it's over.
New year, new me.
New year.
- It's 2022 guys.
- Oh wait, did we,
okay, actually did we say our
like, new year's resolution?
I think we did, 'cause
Chris was on, right?
We said what we wanted to do.
Do you remember what you said?
- Yeah, I mean I-
- I remember what I said.
- What, last year?
- Yeah.
- I don't remember
what I said last year.
- Our first episode
of last year?
- Oh, last year?
- It goes to show, right?
We're all fucking good with
our new year's resolution,
but I remember what I said.
- What did you say?
- I remember
sarcastically saying to Chris,
I wanna be on the Abroad in Japan Channel.
Unfortunately.
- And now you are.
- Unfortunately it's happened many times,
yeah, and it did.
- Oh, you actually got through
with your new year's resolution?
You should be proud.
- You're the first person
I know who actually did their
new year's resolution.
- Cheers to me, boys.
Cheers to me, cheers, cheers.
Celebrate my success, gentlemen.
(speakers laughing)
- Very good.
I appreciate that.
- Wait, that was a...
- I don't think I brought a
New Year's-
- Was this the
Rubik's cube thing?
- What?
- Was yours the Rubik's cube?
Was that 2019?
I think that was 2019,
'cause I've been able to do a Rubik's cube
for the past two years now, at least.
- Yeah, every time we have a
Rubik's cube in the office now,
Joey just goes ahead and solves it,
so he's been able to do it for a while.
I do not remember you saying that
as a new year's resolution,
though.
- I don't think I
gave in years resolution,
'cause I haven't really been a guy to,
like, choose new year's resolutions,
because for the most
like three or four years,
I just haven't been able to do them, so.
- Yeah, it must be like, I
feel bad for the viewers,
who probably think that we have
like dementia or something,
that we can't remember
anything what we've said.
And then we're like,
and we probably had this
conversation last year
where we're like,
"Oh yeah, so we just don't like them,
so we just decided,"
I remember I must've said
something along the lines of,
"I just prefer small goals that I just."
- Yeah, but I can't,
I don't even remember what
I say like a week ago.
Like sometimes I have a
conversation with my mom,
and she was just like,
"Oh yeah, when you were
talking about this,
I can't believe you said that."
And I'm just like,
"Mom, I do not remember
saying those words at all."
- I didn't even remember
what I had for like,
dinner like three days ago.
So it was like, you can't expect
me to remember after like,
what was like a hundred plus hours
of us talking on this show,
but you just like, remember
this one little detail?
It's not gonna happen.
- No, 'cause like, I remember
talking about current events,
Joey's channel right now with the-
- Is in the dire straits.
- Is in the dire straits,
and of course he uploads
to his second channel,
and I see it's blown up, right?
'Cause even my mum,
my mum sends me a message and she's like,
"I just saw that Joey's
channels in trouble.
Have you given him a phone
call to make sure he's okay?"
- And I'm just like, just
breaking down, crying, you know?
Like in my bed, just
weeping into my pillow.
I mean like, as of right now,
it still hasn't been resolved,
but luckily I have contacted YouTube,
and I'm pretty confident
it's gonna get resolved,
so that's why I'm not like,
too stressed about it,
but it was very humbling
when I made that video,
and like, so many people
came to me and was like,
"Yeah, yeah, I'll subscribe and all that."
So thanks if you did.
- I really like, you know...
I like a situation that I
know is gonna be resolved,
but I can still make a
video complaining about it,
because it's, you know.
- You get monetized.
- [Joey] Yeah, you get monetized.
- But also it's pushed
like a week off work,
'cause you don't have to upload that one.
I'm like, fantastic.
- So I can't upload for
two weeks, all right,
'cause of all the-
- Yeah.
- Guys,
I just wanna bring you this content.
I really do, I just,
oh, I just can't.
- Well, you know, it's like,
it is bittersweet, to be fair,
because it's like,
it's cool that this has
been like this explosion
and stuff on the second
channel, but it's like,
I wish I didn't have to resort to this.
I wish it like,
my main channel,
literally on life support,
wasn't the reason why I
was getting all these subs.
- Like, I mean your second channel
has basically been becoming your
anime channel for the long
time, for the longest time.
So what if you just like
migrating the anime man
to just now it's just Joey?
- I mean, I could.
- It's exactly
what you wanted all your career,
right?
- It could, it could happen.
But at the same time, it's like, you know,
I don't wanna lose nine years.
- [Connor] What if you
pulled an epic prank, right?
- Yeah.
- Right?
You just change the names and
pictures of both the channels.
(Joey laughing)
- What like, so Joey has his own?
(speakers laughing)
- Have you thought about it, really, like?
- I mean, it could work.
Maybe for like,
an hour.
- The old switch-a-roo?
- Yeah.
- A good day to switch.
- It's like,
"Yeah guys, sub to my second channel."
Wink, wink.
- JK,
this was the anime man.
- This was the same channel all along.
- And then you like, tell everyone,
like, there's a good group.
You tell everyone, like on Joey,
if you go and comment
on the new Joey channel,
tell them, "Man, I really
love this Joey content."
Just spam all the comments,
so now nobody can see the old comments.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah,
well we can all (indistinct).
- Now this can be the side.
- So if I actually did do it,
"Here you go, guys.
It was a prank, you just got pranked."
- [Connor] I really love
the new Joey channel.
- Yeah.
Nah, but I'm hoping like
next couple of days,
it will get resolved.
- You can't upload for two weeks?
- I can't upload for two weeks, no,
which sucks because I have to like,
'cause especially when
you're dealing with sponsors,
I have to tell them like,
"Oh sorry, YouTube did a big fucky-wucky,
and now I can't upload."
So it's very annoying
having to explain that
to companies who clearly
don't understand, like,
"Just upload."
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- "Your channel's still
there, just upload."
It's like, "No, no, no,
that's not how it works."
- It's just the life of a YouTuber,
where you just wake up one day maybe,
and you just find out that
maybe your career is in danger,
and you're like, "Oh, okay.
I guess all of this is
like, now out of my hands."
- It was so shit as well,
because I got the strike
literally the day,
the night I came back
from Hokkaido, right?
Also it was after a five
day trip with Chris,
and I'm like, all right,
I gotta just relax now,
just get on my computer, maybe watch some,
and my channel's about to die.
Amazing, thanks YouTube.
- I remember I was extremely drunk
when all of my channel
got copyright claimed.
I remember that.
(Joey snickering)
- Okay.
- I was like,
I didn't know how to process it,
because I was drunk, obviously.
- Oh yeah?
- So I was like, 'cause
I just had a night out.
I think I was with Garnt, we
must have had a night out.
I think I was like, just very like.
- Was that the night that you accidentally
deleted one of your videos.
- Oh, that was another night.
- [Joey] That was a different night.
- To be fair, I'm sure we
would have done that as well.
I would have made that mistake.
I do remember, God, I must sound terrible.
- Have we told that story yet?
- We have told that story,
I got really drunk,
and it was like 4:00 AM,
and we were at your friend's house.
But no, I remember
I was on a trip with Garnt,
and we just had like the one night out,
and I was like, yeah, it
was a really good night.
And then it was like 4:00 AM,
and I was about to go to bed.
And then my email was
like, could hear like,
oh poor tuna just playing in my head.
Like YouTube, YouTube, YouTube,
copyright claim has been filed.
I was like...
(Connor sighing heavily)
Like, what do you even do?
Like, do you sober up mentally?
But you're not sober up.
- Yeah.
- You know?
You're like, oh, I'm gonna sleep.
- Yeah, your brain's on a
hundred percent overdrive.
It's just, you can't
do anything about it.
- 'Cause the problem is
you wanna sort it out
there and then, right?
You just wanna like get
in contact with someone,
just know that you're in the
process of it being sorted out,
but a lot of the times,
you just gotta wait,
and you just gotta make noise,
and just gotta like,
hope that someone can
sort this out for you.
- Yeah, have I ever told this story
about what happened to all that?
The one that got caught
with the (indistinct)?
- I think-
- Not on "Trash Taste."
- Yeah, not on "Trash Taste."
- Oh, okay.
So yeah, like twice now
all of my channels has been claimed
for the same reason, twice, right?
So I was using this outro
song that I think I heard,
where did I get it?
I think I heard it on
Sky William's channel,
which is like, that's a fuckin'...
- That's a throwback.
- Yeah, that's a throwback.
He used it as his outro.
I thought, "I like that."
And also I was like, I
had like a hundred subs,
so I thought, "It's okay if I just like,
take the same outro, right?"
- Of course.
- "No one's gonna see it."
And then obviously like, people saw it.
- [Joey] I'm like,
got some Sky Williams fans.
- 'Cause people loved it,
'cause he was a banger.
- Yeah.
(speakers laughing)
- Such a banger in fact,
that I had to buy license.
- [Joey] Oh.
- And I didn't know there was
an original, original song,
I just thought it was just this one song.
- Right, so you had the remix version?
- So I had the remix version.
I didn't know that it was a remix, right?
So I went to the artist who made it,
and the song had a lot of views.
It was called like, "Do
it for Love" or something.
- Right.
- And I had this, and I used
this on every single video.
- [Joey] Well yeah, it was your outro.
Yeah, then of course,
this come to bite me in the ass.
I didn't just play it
when the video ended,
it would like fade into the video.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Right, right, right.
- So this will come back to bite me later.
So I got, in like 2000, maybe '17 or '16,
I got, I wanna say 80% of my
channel copyright claimed.
And this is on the old system as well,
where it wouldn't tell you,
which I think it didn't tell you
which time it was copyright claimed.
It would just say you've
been copyright claimed,
this is the thing.
- Yeah.
- And it was by a company that was
on behalf of the artist
who I purchased the license from for $50.
I bought this license.
Back then I thought, "Holy
shit, it's so much money.
Oh my God, this is how
much the licenses cost?"
- It's like a whole month on YouTube.
- So I'm like, well basically.
- At that time.
- At that time,
it was like a lot of money, you know?
And this is back when I was
terrified of everything,
and I remember I bought
licenses to fonts and shit.
I'm pretty sure I'm the only
person on earth who paid
for license for a font.
- Have you paid for WinRAR?
(Garnt laughing)
- I want to though,
just to tell the guy I appreciate it.
- But you have to be above
the age of 70 to do it.
- I wanna meet a single
person who has paid
for WinRAR.
- I'm gonna do it
on live stream, I'm gonna do it live.
- [Joey] Just to see what happens?
- I just wanna see what happens.
What happens?
- Do you just explode?
So it's like...
(Joey groans)
We weren't designed for this.
(speakers laughing)
- The stream just ends.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I buy WinRAR.
- It's like a test.
You win life at that point, you know?
- It's like, congratulations.
- The simulation shuts down,
and you just see like the congrat,
like the entire world just
disintegrates around you.
- You just wake up like...
(Joey gasping)
- You know the Bible story from like,
a hundred episodes ago?
It's just that.
It's like, there are
people who pay for WinRAR,
and there are people who don't.
- [Joey] God comes down and says stop.
- You know the flying society thing?
Like, society, everyone paid for WinRAR.
(speakers laughing)
So I paid for this license
and whatnot, right?
And I angrily emailed the guy.
Bear in mind, I was like 19,
so I was like trying to conduct
myself as a businessman,
but I didn't know what
the fuck I was doing.
- Yeah.
- So I angrily emailed him
from my Hotmail account,
and I instructed him that
I'd purchased this license,
please tell this person to stop.
And so this whole thing where
the guy wrote me an email being like,
"Hey, you have my word that
you bought the license."
And I had like, PayPal receipts.
So then I had to email this company
that was claiming on behalf,
which I think was Distrokid.
So he had put this song in
a copyright claiming thing,
so it went around.
So I had a bit of
difficulty, it took a while,
but I eventually got Distrokid to like,
stop claiming my stuff,
and they stopped claiming
it all, and it was good.
I can't remember how I did it.
It was like this long,
whole process, it was awful.
And then all good, all good.
I kept using the outro after that.
This is where I should
have learned my lesson,
and changed the outro, but I'd thought,
"I'd won the battle.
I'd won it, I'd done it."
- Also, the song is a banger.
- The song kind of slaps, right?
I'd thought, okay,
I'd proven to some entity
that this is legit,
and I have the artist who
says that it's all good.
And I thought, okay, this is it.
I'm good to use this now.
Like, I paid for it.
I got proof and we're all Gucci.
- Yeah.
- And so I carry on using it.
And then, maybe a year later, I wanna say,
I don't know how long
exactly, there was a timeline,
I get claimed again.
This time, like two-thirds
of my channel, I want to say,
and this is right before they
added the option to mute.
- [Joey] Right.
- Right, right, right.
- So like, now if you
get copyright claimed,
'cause sometimes there's
still bullshit claims.
They'll find like one second,
and then they'll say "We
own the entire video."
So just mute it for one second.
Fuck off,
you can have it.
- You can mute it,
or delete the segments,
which is one of the more positive changes
YouTube has made.
- A Godsend.
- You know?
- Definitely.
- And unfortunately
this situation happened,
I wanna say like, one before
they introduced that tool.
- Yeah.
- So I got all of my thing claimed,
and I was kind of like,
what the fuck do I do?
Because two thirds of
my revenue just like,
got Thanos'd away.
And this happened to my channel for about,
I wanna say two months straight.
So for two months straight,
my earnings are like this.
- Yeah.
- And I lost so much money
that I never got back,
so it's very, very,
I'm still to this day
quite annoyed about that.
And I went on this whole thing of like,
all right, what the fuck is going on?
So, it was like Warner Brothers
or something had claimed it
on behalf of some artists
that I'd never heard of.
I go, and I find out
that this was a remix,
and I'm like, oh shit, I didn't know.
And apparently this was like a big artist,
and I'm an idiot,
'cause I didn't know who this person was.
- That's probably why it was a banger.
- Yeah.
- That's why it was a banger.
And so, I was like,
okay, so this is weird.
So I thought that he sold me this license,
and it was good.
So I very confidently counter
every single claim thinking,
"I've got the license, it's all good,"
and then I get denied.
And then I appeal them
as well, which is like,
if you lose all these appeals,
your channel gets deleted.
So I appealed a bunch of them,
and for some reason I just
got denied the appeal,
but nothing happened.
- Right.
- So I just couldn't
appeal again, it was weird.
And so now, now I was starting
to be like, what the fuck?
Like, what's going on?
I counted all these claims and
stuff and nothing happened,
and I don't really know what to do now.
So I remember I got in touch
with the guy who I
bought the license from,
who was the artist who made the song.
I was like, "Hey, what the fuck?
What's going on, man?
You sold me a license.
Is it good, or is it not?"
And he's like, "Well, I have
the license to make the remix,
but I don't think,"
and then he was like, "I'm not
sure what I can and can't,"
and I'm like.
- Oh, wow.
- I'm like, what?
What?
And then I asked a YouTube
man who is a lawyer man.
He gave me advice that
was not legal advice.
Every single sentence ended with,
"This is not legal advice,"
He basically informed me that yeah,
this license was no good.
It was like nothing.
- Bogus.
- Whether the artist knew
that or not, I don't know.
He might genuinely not have known.
So he basically-
- Well if he's like an
Indie artist as well,
he's probably-
- Yeah, yeah.
I assumed that he didn't fully know.
- Do you stroke it?
I don't think he knew.
- I don't know.
- It was a weird thing, and I was like,
and so I asked the guy,
I went had like really angry DMs with him
back and forth where I'm like,
"So can I use this?
Did you fuck me over?"
Like, "Do you know how
much this fucks me?"
Like, "What am I supposed to do?"
And so in the end it turned out, yeah,
I was in the wrong,
because I had been sold this bogus license
that was like, not real.
- Yeah.
- And so then I was like,
well fuck, what do I do now?
I've just lost like three or four,
I think it was three years of YouTube work
that is just gone.
I just can't use any of it.
- So scary, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And so I made this video ranting,
being like, "Fuck."
Like, "What do I do?
That's just so fucked.
I've been wronged," et cetera, et cetera.
And you know, and I YouTube
for help at the time,
they just didn't help me.
And I was like, well,
what the fuck am I doing?
And then funny enough,
I had a YouTube partner manager
before all of this went down
who was really good, surprisingly,
because normally they don't talk to you.
- Right.
- And then that person left the company,
and then I got someone new,
and they introduced
themselves through an email,
and then never heard from them again.
(Joey snorting)
- That's how it always is.
- That's how it is, yeah.
- And so I went on like
a mini-rant in this video
being like, Yeah, YouTube is useless.
They don't do anything.
I have the shoe-shoe person.
They never talked to me.
They don't help me at all."
After that video goes live,
I got an email from a YouTube person.
It was like, "Hey."
- Of course.
- "Hey, I'm that person
that you were like,
was saying that was useless.
- Shit-talking?
- Yeah.
(Joey laughing)
And they were like,
"Yeah, I'd actually like to
help your situation out."
And I was like, "Oh, okay, that's great.
Awesome."
- Yeah.
- So they basically said,
"Hey, so what we can do
is we can go through every single video,
and if you send me the file again,
without the music in it,
we can replace the video
and take off the thing."
- Like on the back?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So, I had to go through 200
videos, and re-render them,
or just cut out the music,
'cause some of the files,
I didn't have the original files anymore.
Like, the Adobe file or
whatever, like it was tough.
Luckily, a lot of the more recent ones,
the ones I liked and was more proud of,
like at that time.
- You had the original files.
- I had the original files.
So, we had like 200 videos on Google Drive
linked in an Excel spreadsheet,
and then we had to one by one swap them.
But this process wasn't perfect either,
because videos got uploaded
to the wrong video.
- Oh, right, right, right.
- So like.
- So you'd click on a
certain thumbnail and title,
and it took you to a
different video, right?
- It was like, that
was the original video,
and then they replaced
it with another video
that got put there.
Like I did like, there was like a,
I remember it was an "Attack
on Titan" impressions,
and "Yuri on Ice" impressions.
They both got swapped,
so when people went to
"Yuri on Ice" impressions,
it was just me doing
"Attack on Titan" things,
and then when it was the other one,
it was the other video.
And I sat there with
YouTube for like an hour
trying to explain to
them what was happening,
because the subtitles also got swapped.
So they were looking at the
video only in the subtitles,
like the raw subtitle data,
and they were like, "No,
no, it's the right one.
You're talking about 'Yuri on Ice'
in the subtitles or something,"
and I was like, "No,
no, no, no, the video,
the video is wrong."
And I was like panicking,
and I was getting tons
of comments being like,
what the fuck is going on?
And I'm like, fix this.
- Did you not just like,
swap the titles around?
- It was just weird,
because all the entire video
is swapped.
- Did you see what Joey is
gonna do with this channel?
(Garnt laughing)
- Do a whole switch-a-roo.
- I wonder what the side
effects are of this is like,
so eventually we got it all sorted.
- You just go on the channel when like,
why has this "Attack on Titan"
video got "Yuri on Ice?"
Like, what's going on there?
- Exactly, so all the
comments were like that too.
- I don't remember Yuri
in "Attack on Titans."
- Right, right, right.
So it was all weird, and then like, again,
like two months later,
it finally all got done, and we did it.
Some of the videos, like I
said, they couldn't be salvaged.
And the reason why it
came to bite me back later
was because some outros in
my videos now, I just mute.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So you can't hear anything.
- Also 'cause like, I
had the exact same thing,
but after YouTube introduced
the whole muting thing.
So I had my old, old intro.
So my current intro now is
made by my friend from uni
who used to be like a music
producer and it's like,
not even out on like
any website or anything.
So I know it's like, good.
It's all copyright free,
because I had the exact
same thing where I saw,
like I went on to like SoundCloud,
and I found like this
really like banger song.
And I was like,
"Oh, cool, I'll use it as an outro,"
'cause it's like kind of wacky, goofy.
Like, you know, all the gaming YouTube
was using it at the time.
And then of course,
that artist got really
popular on SoundCloud.
- [Garnt] Because every
YouTuber was using.
- Got a major record label because of it,
and then the record label
copywrite claimed all of my shit.
- [Connor] Oh, shit.
- And I had, same thing,
I DM'd the artist, I was like,
"Yeah, so what's happening now?
You said I could use it."
And she's like, "Yeah, but
I'm like a big shot now.
I got a major record
label, and unfortunately,
I can't do anything for you."
But luckily this was
during the time where,
again, YouTube introduced
the muting thing.
- Still kind of shitty of them to not,
if you asked, did you ask
them permission initially?
- Yeah, yeah.
So I asked, so I DM'd the artist initially
when she was just on SoundCloud,
and she was like, "Yeah,
please, go for it.
Like, I'd love that."
Like just, you know, obviously.
- That's kind of fucked up, what the heck?
- "Just link it in the
description, you'll be all good."
I was like, oh sweet,
that's very nice of her.
And then yeah, she was like,
"Well, sorry.
That's not my decision,
that's my label's decision.
So, sorry."
- [Connor] So shitty.
- So like, if you go back
to videos from like 2017,
where I use that outro,
they're all mute at the end.
- Yeah, I've got a lot of videos
where it's just me talking at the end,
and I still get comments
just saying, being like,
"Why does it just go silent?"
(Joey laughing)
And I'm like, "Yeah, man."
- Yeah, I mean, I've
had to use that feature
for some of my videos,
but like I don't mute it.
I just cut out like the-
- Yeah, now you can replace the music.
- Yeah, you can replace the music,
'cause I believe I had to
do that for "Trash Taste"
or something, right?
Because that got copyright
claimed or something.
one of the specials, or something.
Oh, and "After Dark" as well.
For some reason I'll
intro for "Trash Taste"
got copyright claims, and after that-
- [Joey] On Twitch.
- On Twitch.
- A royalty-free song.
- Yeah.
- It's a royalty-free
song, but Twitch was like,
"No, no, no, no."
- Well the copywrite
system's unfortunately
really easy to abuse.
Like, you can stick any
old fuckin' piece of music,
and start claiming shit,
and it's only until
somebody like, stops you.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- So, you know.
- It was like the weirdest
copyright claimed I've gotten
is like for anime music that
I've put into my videos.
Like before, like anime
oversees were just free game,
because Japan, the anime industry
didn't really give a shit.
And now they're slowly coming
to realize, wait a minute,
YouTubers use our music.
How can this be?
So like now anime OSTs are
starting to be claimed as well,
but I didn't get claimed by
one of the anime companies.
So I, in one of my videos,
I had "You Say Run" on it,
and I got claimed, and
"You Say Run" got claimed,
but it didn't get claimed,
it got claimed by our cover of
"You Say Run."
- What?
- So a YouTuber who I believe
is signed with a record label
also made a video where they
made a cover of "You Say Run,"
and that's got like, the
original "You Say Run"
that I used in my video
got claimed by a cover
of "You Say Run".
- Right, right.
- And yeah, that's,
where do I even begin with that, you know?
Like that's a.
- I mean, yeah, like super
early in my YouTube channel,
I used to do like covers of anime songs,
like on guitar and piano
and stuff like that.
Reason of why I don't do that anymore,
it's because the few times I
ever got a copyright strike,
not a claim, a strike
was from a cover I did.
I did a cover of fuckin'
"Paranoid Android" by Radiohead,
because it was the ending to "Ergo Proxy,"
and at the time it was
like, I really liked it.
And yeah, I got a fucking strike on it.
And I was like,
I'm not sure if that can
also be a humblebrag,
because that's like saying
like, you were so good.
I covered it.
- YouTube literally
thought it was the real thing.
- YouTube thought it was
the original song.
I was like, "Thanks YouTube,
but also, what the fuck?
- I've had my voice claimed
a few times actually.
- Really?
- Yeah, my own videos.
People trying to claim my like,
say like, where I'm just
talking, there's nothing.
- That's obviously not VA.
- Oh, I've seen a TikTok of that.
(Joey laughing)
- It's weird, it's weird,
it's pretty bizarre.
Like, I don't know.
- I've never heard of that.
- I heard like, an original
as one dude on YouTube,
one time he uploaded his original song,
and then got claimed by someone,
someone claimed his original song
that he uploaded to his own channel.
- [Joey] How?
- Well, 'cause anyone
can put anything content.
- [Joey] Oh, that's true.
- Like, these companies
are given free reign.
- Yeah, remember there was like,
I forgot when it was,
it was like maybe 2018,
there was like that copyright
Armageddon that was happening
where like all these
like fake companies were
going around, and just like striking?
- I mean, it's still
happening, because like-
- It's not as bad as
it used to be, though.
- It's not, it definitely isn't,
and I'm glad, like one
of the positive things
YouTube has done has given
creators tools to like,
for example, cut or mute the segment
that has been copyright claimed it out,
which we just didn't have before.
So if we've got a copyright claim before
for like a second of music,
then there was just like,
nothing we could do.
It was just like a dead video.
- Man, you know what companies suck?
Well, there's fuckin' like,
Viral Hog and all those dudes,
the ones that buy viral videos.
- Oh.
- And just go around claiming
them, and like Armageddon,
like, fuckin' awful.
- Like Nine Gag and stuff like that?
- No, no, no.
So they're like these,
you know when you see
those watermarks on Facebook?
You know, do you remember that video
of that dude punching the kangaroo?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- LADBible?
- Kinda like that, but a bit different,
because LADBible,
they don't normally go
around copyright claim,
but that video, right?
The person who had that video
sold it to this company,
and then what they do
is everyone who's then
talking about it was showing it,
they'll just go around and
copyright claiming everything,
and any of these news networks.
- [Joey] That's scummy.
- Well that's the business model,
like they buy these videos
for like very cheap,
even like, have you ever had offers
from people who wanna buy your videos?
- Yeah.
- It's really weird,
yeah.
- I've had that.
- They'll go around buying them,
and then just claim everything,
and it's just, yeah.
It's really shit,
'cause people react to
stuff on stream as well.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that's true.
- And also the worst thing is about that,
luckily I'm 99% of you will
never have to experience
is that these copyright claims, right?
Sometimes they're like
really fucking generous
with the timing on the video.
Like, so they have to say
what time in the video
they copyright claimed,
and sometimes they'll add on like,
5 or 10 seconds to the end,
and I'm like, "You piece of shit."
Now I've got to like,
it was like a clear edit and everything.
I've got to edit out or mute shit,
'cause you don't get to contest the time,
so whatever the time is,
that's like, if you wanna
mute the corporate content,
you don't get to say where it is.
It's whatever they submitted is it.
So one time, on one video,
I remember I reacted to
like a clip or something
on a live stream or something or Connadog.
And they claimed it and I
was like, that's fair enough.
But then they claimed
like 40 seconds extra,
nothing to do with said clip.
- [Joey] Wow.
- And I was like, "Wow dude, like really?"
Like a four second clip.
- They own your
reaction as well.
- Nah, nah.
The videos like that,
where I react to shit,
I don't give a fuck,
but it's like, bro, what are you doing?
Don't claim shit that isn't
the video, like, come on.
You're just lazy, you don't want
to put in the time.
- But that's the problem,
right, it's like,
I feel like YouTube has done
a really good job of like,
trying to make the playing field
as fair as possible, right?
Like only recently they added
that whole thing of like,
how during an appealing process,
the money that the video accumulates
goes into what's called
escrow, which is like kind of-
- [Connor] What you should've done anyway.
- Yeah, it's kind of like,
it doesn't go to the person who
is the supposed copyright
holder, or the video owner,
it kind of like, it's
floating in the cloud
until it's resolved.
- [Connor] Yeah, it's like-
- Which is great,
it's fantastic.
- It's like if you
put in a pool.
No one can get that until
the copyright situation
is resolved.
- Which is fantastic, but
like at the same time,
even today I feel the advantage
is still in the claimant.
Clearly YouTube is like, yeah,
obviously if you're
gonna go out of your way
to claim something copyright-wise,
then you must have a good reason for it,
but a lot of companies don't.
Thank you to Ayylien Clothing
for sponsoring this video today.
- [Joey] Ayylien is an indie
street-wear clothing company
started in early 2017 by YouTube
creator, Elvis The Ayylien,
who's also happens to
be a personal friend.
- Oh.
- [Joey] With the support and love
from the YouTube community,
it has grown beyond his wildest dreams.
Elvis created Ayylien for
people like him who loved games,
anime, movies, and
anything science fiction.
- Just like you, Joey.
- I love all of those things.
Impress your grandma by wearing a monster,
android, or alien.
Stay spaced out, and never
compromise your sense of self.
Ayylien helps people who wish to embrace
the bold and strange
through clothing expression.
- [Connor] Ayylien's designs
are very carefully created
by some of the best artists
who are around the world.
The items are printed,
shipped, and handled with care
from their team in Canada.
Get what you can before they're sold out,
most items are never restocked,
but fear not, Ayylien
is constantly coming out
with new creative designs,
and Ayylien uses only
the best quality fabrics
available on the market,
while still trying their best
to keep every item affordable.
Ayylien items are sold
by popular skate shop,
Zoomies in Canada, and hope
to expand more in future.
So, if you wanna save 20% off
using the code trashtaste,
any orders over $100 get free shipping.
- Damn.
- [Speaker 2] In case you missed that,
it's ayylienclothing.com.
- So smash that link in the description
to get your own Ayylien products today.
- Thank you Ayylien clothing
for sponsoring this episode,
back to the video.
But speaking of like other
changes that YouTube has made.
- Now the dust has settled
on the first like thing.
- Yeah, so like, has
dislikes been removed?
I'm very confused,
because I can still
see them on my channel.
- It's a slow process.
- On your channel, yeah.
Not on anyone else's.
- Yeah, on anyone else's channel though,
it should be completely gone.
- No, I can see, I can still
see it on videos, I think.
Let me check, let me check.
- [Joey] I know that-
- Oh no, it's gone.
No.
No, literally, I was literally-
- It's been like that for days.
- No, no, no, I literally looked
at fuckin' videos yesterday
and I was just like, what
is the dislike channel?
And then where is the dislikes going?
- Yeah, it's getting like
slowly implemented, I think,
so not all channel owners can see,
but like at least with your own content,
you can still see your dislikes,
which goes completely against
the argument that YouTube made
as to why they wanted to
get rid of the dislikes.
Because I remember I made a
video on a second channel,
and one of the YouTube reasonings
for getting rid of the
dislike button was that like,
oh if you see dislikes on your videos,
it discourages smaller creators, you know?
Perhaps they're getting disliked bombed,
perhaps they're getting bullied,
and no one likes to see
a bunch of dislikes.
Yet, you can still see
dislikes on your own videos,
so what the fuck?
- You know, I'm just
glad they're standing up
for the small creators,
all two of them or something that exists
on the entire platform of YouTube
that have ever complained about this.
Because I was talking to this about,
with a bunch of other YouTubers,
and I asked them, do you
know a single creator
in your field that has ever
complained about dislike bombs?
Like whatever size, and
not a single person I know
has ever been like a
target of dislike bombs
to the point where it actually
actively ruins their channel.
- Yeah.
- You know?
- Have you ever received
a lot of dislikes?
- Yeah.
- I mean, yeah,
I mean, 'cause I feel,
me and Garnt make more opinionated videos
than you do, right?
So obviously there are some opinions
I've said in the past
that people aren't very
happy with.
- I've never really
had a lot of dislikes on one video.
- I've had some videos
that didn't do as well.
- Well, what do you classify
as a lot of dislikes?
- More than...
- Like 10%?
- Yeah, 10% is quite a lot.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
Yeah, I've had a few
videos, but not that much.
- I don't have that much,
most of it is like the more
controversial opinion videos,
but in general-
- All people
who didn't like, watch the video
up to the end.
- I think I've had 10%.
- I think the only one was the...
- The Christian one.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Understandable.
- Not everyone's cup of tea.
- Yeah, but, no, I've had
a few where it's like,
when I look back on those videos,
or like how I presented them,
I can see why they got dislike bombed,
and I don't really blame them for it.
I guess I remember like,
I think one that really blew up recently
that got quite a few
dislikes, I think it is like,
a nine to one is,
it's an old "Let's Fight" episode,
where the title of it is,
"Beserk is Not a Masterpiece,"
I think.
- [Connor] Dislike.
- And it's like, right now,
I think it's at 10 or 15% dislike,
and it only blow up after
Mira-sensei's par scene, right?
Because obviously people were searching
of "Beserk" and all that, and obviously,
if you watch the video,
I argue against that.
- You'd know that Joey is like
the biggest "Beserk" simp.
- Yeah.
- Like, ever.
- That was the title.
I used that because that was
one of the opinions I got,
and I fought against it,
but clearly people don't
watch it all the way through
or up to that point,
so they just see the title and they think,
"Oh, this guy hates Beserk, dislike."
- In some ways I, you know,
I personally liked the dislike button,
but in other ways I think it
doesn't really do anything,
and it doesn't serve.
The only place-
- Have you ever
actively disliked a video?
- Yeah, yes.
- Yes, yeah.
- Okay, but here's the problem, right?
- For what reason?
- Yeah but, this is the problem, right?
There's no agreed upon
consensus on when you dislike.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- You could dislike because
you disagree with the opinion,
you could dislike because
you didn't enjoy the video
as much as another one,
you could dislike because you
just don't like the person.
I feel like the dislike,
although is sometimes
helpful on a tutorial, yes.
It's very black and white.
Is the tutorial not good?
Dislike.
Like, when it comes to like your videos,
I feel like the dislike bar
doesn't serve the same purpose
as it does on a tutorial,
where information is actually important.
- I think it serves a
purpose when you know
like you really fucked up, you know?
- Again, that, again, there.
- Or you've purposely
made a very controversial
opinion, right?
- Yeah, and the more I think about it,
the more I think, yeah, okay,
in some ways the dislike
and like bar is useless,
like it doesn't mean anything.
With 99% of videos, I think
it is completely useless,
and only with tutorials and
knowing when you fucked up,
that's literally the only two reasons.
- Well, I mean, there
is also some catharsis
to being able to dislike
a video, and just like,
sometimes you see a video,
and it's so outrageous,
and you wanna know that you're
not the only fucking person
who thinks that this video is like,
that this is a shitty video or something,
and you go to the dislike
bar and you're like,
"Thank God, I'm not the
only one," you know?
There is some catharsis.
It's like going into a video and seeing
comments are disabled, and
I'm just like, fuck you.
Fuck you.
- Yeah but that's way-
- No balls.
- The like and dislike bar's like nothing,
it's the comments that matter, I think.
And when the come to the disabled,
I get way more than I do.
- Right, like to me, it's like,
I don't mind if you
disagree with an opinion
I make on a video,
but I would much rather
you leave a comment
explaining why you dislike it,
or why you are against
whatever I said in that video
rather than just like leaving a dislike.
Because, again, as you said,
a dislike can mean a
million different things.
- Because sometimes people will be like,
"This video wasn't as
good as another one."
Does that mean that
that person disliked it?
And is that like, fair?
'Cause if I didn't like the
video that someone made,
or I liked another one more,
I wouldn't personally dislike.
- No.
- But that's how I do it.
So, to me trying to like
extrapolate any information
from this random just metric
that doesn't mean shit,
like, it doesn't help me.
Like, when I see a video
that has 99.9% likes,
I'm like, okay.
Now I see a video with 99.8% likes.
I'm like, what's the difference here?
Like, did it get more
likes than previously,
or like, less dislikes?
I don't really understand.
- [Joey] Yeah, I've never really-
- No, but I mean, like,
I think it is useful,
not in the small percentages,
but in the large percentages, right?
Because most videos on
YouTube should have like,
an above 90% like ratio,
like to dislike ratio.
- I think it's actually 99,
is like normally good.
95 is where you're getting
to like, all right.
Maybe have said something
low, a little bad.
If it's 10%, if you have 9 to 1 ratio,
you've probably fucked up.
- Oh no, you haven't fucked up,
you've just pissed off...
My experience is you've
probably pissed off-
- A certain group.
- A certain community or
a certain group, you know?
And then you get to like the 50%,
and that's when you know that
something big has gone down.
- Yeah, 'cause your core
audience will always like,
I mean that's really-
- But that doesn't
necessarily like, for example,
like a channel I like to
watch a lot of is "Needledrop"
who does like a lot of
music reviews, right?
He's had a couple of recent,
before the dislikes disappeared,
he's had a couple of
videos that were like,
40% likes, but it was
still like a good video.
It was just the thing,
his opinion about it,
obviously didn't coincide
with the general public.
- Right, so but like, what does that,
as a viewer, what do I then
gather from that video?
- [Joey] Right.
I'm like, is this a bad video?
- Yeah, does he say something
that's flat out wrong?
Does he say something that a lot of people
just don't agree with?
Like, it doesn't really tell you anything
in that scenario.
- It's a mixture
of all those, right?
And that's why you have to
go down into the comments
after that to be like, okay,
what is the reasoning
behind this massive dislike?
- Yeah, but like,
I feel like YouTube removing
this way for viewers
to express themselves or
like the distaste of a video,
they're going to find other ways
to express their distaste towards a video.
Like, I'm sure ratioing is just now-
- Ratio, yeah, ratio.
- It's going to now be a fuckin'
thing in the YouTubesphere.
- As if it I wasn't
already fucking annoying.
- Yeah, I can't wait to like,
comments to like ratio
YouTube videos though.
'Cause that's just, that's
what's going to happen, you know?
- Viewers always find, like
audiences always find a way
to show you their dislike.
- Yeah.
- It's either
the YouTube comments are
gonna get more toxic,
or other social media platforms that
that particular YouTuber is known to be on
is gonna get more toxic behavior.
- Because like, the biggest
thing that annoys me is
the tutorials and stuff,
because you are very
much removing an easy way
to discern whether our tutorial is right,
or whether a certain video is right.
Because let's say you
upload a shitty tutorial,
or you upload a scam, right?
You disabled comments,
but likes and dislikes is still available,
are still up in the open.
So you're kind of just like,
you're just kind of like taking a risk
on whether you should
listen to them, right?
Because you don't know
how many people disabled.
- But also likes are very
easy to manipulate as well,
like that's another thing.
- Well, but I would argue that-
- [Connor] At a smaller level.
- Yeah, but I would argue that now
that you can't even see
the dislikes anymore,
there's not even point
of disabling likes and
dislikes anymore, right?
Because it's just in a
constant, disabled state, right?
Because it's like, you can only,
like say for example
there was a scam video.
If they disabled the comments,
now what's the only thing you can see?
Is the likes.
It's like...
- I mean.
- You can't do
anything about that.
- 'Cause like, I think
YouTube were trying to go
for something similar
to what Instagram did
with their likes about
making likes not public,
except for the poster.
And like for Instagram, I get it for that.
You know, for that platform,
I think it made sense because-
- They reverted it.
The reversed it.
- Did they?
- Yeah.
- Wait.
- When?
- I can see all the likes.
Yeah, they reversed it?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, they reverted it.
- Yeah, they reverted it.
- Since how long?
- Like a long time now.
- Holy shit.
Okay well-
- Were you still under the
impression that that was?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Well we can see how often
Garnt goes on his Instagram.
- It's no big secret that
I don't go on Instagram,
so I guess my point is now mute.
(Joey laughing)
Well fuck.
I'm glad you guys stopped
me before I was starting,
before I was going to start
spewing a lot of bullshit.
- [Speaker 3] Mine is not showing.
- No, they show up for me.
- They show up for me.
- [Speaker 3] You too? They don't.
- Yeah, they show up for me.
I think they might be
slowly rolling it back out,
or you have to like maybe
opt-in to it, or something.
I don't know, but.
- Yeah, see?
- That must be data that shows,
on their end, right?
That like says, hey, when
people all see likes,
it's good for us.
- Yeah.
- And I don't know what that is.
I can only speak to.
- It's probably, if people can see likes,
it just keeps them on the platform,
because viewers wanna feel
like they're having some,
like they can contribute in
some way, shape, or form.
- They wanna see a metric,
and they wanna see that metric go up.
- With the YouTube one,
the main speculation was
that brands weren't happy
with the dislike box.
- Now, in some ways I feel like
that's too easy of an explanation.
I feel like, usually in the past,
I don't think they've been
that catering of brands.
I don't know, I could be wrong here.
I feel like they must have
some data that backs up
that removing dislikes
will lead to better views or something.
- Yeah, I mean.
- They must,
because there's no way that,
YouTube's seems too selfish
to do something for brands.
It seems like, I feel
it just happens to be.
- No, so the YouTube
creator's channel on YouTube
made a video, it was
like a three-minute video
that was like concise saying
why they were moving it.
- Yeah, was it the dude who's like,
is that the one that the
guy was like sitting there?
- Yeah, yeah, the guys just
sitting there being like,
"This is the reason
why we're gonna do it."
Nice and quick, I give him props for that.
At least it wasn't like a fuckin'
30-minute explanation video.
- Yeah.
- But like,
they gave a number
- It sort of fuckin'
like Nickacado Avocado.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Exactly, exactly.
It was nice and concise, which is nice.
But, yeah one of the
reasons they gave was like,
"Oh yeah, we saw a metric
that we tested upon
millions of users," don't
know how true that is,
that apparently the amount of dislikes
does not change the
watch time of that video.
- I believe that.
- Yeah, I believe that
as well.
- Yeah, and I'm like, yeah.
I mean, of course.
- I'd argue-
- I don't really watch.
- That's not a reason though,
to get rid of it.
- To (indistinct)
with dislikes.
- Yeah, exactly.
'Cause I argued being like,
well yeah, what if you're
watching like an apology video
that's like 40 minutes long, right?
I'm sure there's a lot of dislikes on it,
but people wanna see it until the end.
- I mean you usually there's one priority,
it's making people watch longer,
so there must be some evidence
to prove that getting rid of
it makes people watch longer.
- I did find a funny though
that the last point
they gave that was like,
"And the last question is,
did we get rid of the dislike button
because of YouTube rewind?"
They brought that point by,
and dude, I've never seen a guy say no
with such coping in my life.
He was like, "No."
You can see the coping in his eyes.
- You could see how many
times he had to film that
to sound genuine,
to get the most genuine
take that he could,
because he knew people were gonna be
watching this under a microscope at like,
0.25 speed or something to be like,
"Well, the inflection in his voice
kind of leads me to believe that YouTube
made him say that."
- "I heard a slight
vibrato in his voice,
meaning he is about to
start crying at any minute."
- I just wish they
would tell us the truth,
and give us some data, but
they're not gonna do that.
Why would they?
- No.
- I mean, what, like...
What, not annoyed me, but the way,
what really made me suspicious
was the way they framed it
to like, "Oh, we're
doing you guys a favor."
- You asked for this.
- Don't, don't, don't.
Thank us later.
Please, please.
Hold the applause,
but we are helping you
for your mental health.
And it's just like,
literally no creator I have
talked to or ever heard of
asked YouTube to do this,
and they framed it in a way
that they're doing it for the creators.
- [Joey] Have you ever
seen a YouTube creator
make a video in front of the camera going,
"Guys, my mental health is deteriorating
from all these dislikes
I'm getting, man, fuck."
No, of course not.
It's the fucking algorithm
that's demanding YouTuber's
to not take a break.
- It's the one time a
corporation has said,
"Don't worry guys, we've heard you."
(Joey cackling)
The audience didn't actually say anything.
(Garnt laughing)
- We have been silent.
(Garnt and Connor laughing)
You've had tape on our
mouths the entire time.
We can't say anything.
- That's true, that's true.
Hey you guys, we're gonna
help you guys out here.
- There's like, no one.
(speakers laughing)
I don't even know why I'm here, dude.
- It's literally the,
"I've saved the day,"
"But you haven't done anything,"
and they just leave.
(Garnt laughing)
- You're welcome, see ya.
My God.
- Oh my God.
- So I've finally started to
settle in my new place now.
- [Joey] Oh yeah?
- Yeah, we are-
- 20 years later.
- 20 years later, you know?
Hosted the house warming.
Unfortunately, Joey couldn't make it,
because you were busy with the.
- I was doing (indistinct), yeah.
- I will say, yeah.
- Lovely lasagna.
- Yeah, I will say, ever since that day.
So, okay.
So I don't know if I've told the story
of the world-famous lasagna yet,
which it's not world-famous.
- [Joey] But it's about to be.
- Okay, now it's about to be,
so in Japan, I don't know why,
but you can get a lot of
good Italian food in Japan,
but for some reason you
just can't get lasagna.
Like, no Italian restaurant in Japan,
for some reason, serves lasagna.
And the few that they do,
they definitely don't serve good lasagna.
So because of this, I would just like,
look, I've been living
in Japan for a year.
I'm craving lasagna.
So what better way to
do it than just learn
how to do it yourself?
- I'll do it myself,
damn it.
- I fuckin',
I literally fuckin' Thanos,
I'll fuckin' do it myself, right?
So about a year ago.
- I didn't realize that
was a Thanos reference.
I just said it.
- Is it a Thanos reference?
- Yeah.
- I don't know.
- It's the one where
he takes the gauntlet,
and says fine, I'll do it myself.
- [Speaker 4] Yeah.
- I haven't seen the movie.
I've just seen the meme.
- It's a pretty famous meme.
- It's the most generic line
that could be attached to any character.
- I can say anything.
I can be like, "Oh my penis
is a little bit itchy."
She's like, "I don't remember
when Thanos said that."
- I'll do it myself.
- All right, go on, tell it.
- So about a year ago, I
learned how to cook lasagna,
and I cooked it once, right?
I cook it once, and it was
like a mediocre lasagna.
- And it's a difficult dish, right?
- Yeah, I mean...
Kind of.
- It's like lego,
but with pasta.
- Yeah, it's like-
- It's cool.
- It's a pasta cake, right?
It's just concentrated
pasta, with meat of course.
- Yeah, it kind of is.
- That's kind of what it is.
- It's like all the flavor of pasta bowl,
layered out very precisely.
- Right, yeah.
- Yeah, right.
- So, deep during quarantine,
sometimes we would have dinner parties
where we would invite people over,
or just people would come over.
And one day Sydney invites Connor over,
and she says, "Oh, you
can have some of Garnt's
world-famous lasagna."
And I'm just like,
and Connor's just like, what?
I'm just like, what?
What do you mean world-famous,
Cindy, I've cooked it once.
And ever since she said that,
because she didn't say it to Connor,
she said it's a Mae Lynne as well.
And so for like a good five months,
people have built up this idea
that I make world-famous lasagna,
right?
- It's just a joke.
- He's just out here like,
misinformation.
- I would just drop people,
"Have you had Garnt's
world-famous lasagna?
- Yeah.
And so the first time I
actually cook it for Mae Lynne,
Mae Lynne's the one I
wanna please the most.
- [Joey] Of course.
- You want to get that
good Google review.
- Yeah, yeah,
of course, of course.
Because if you can please
Mae Lynne with a meal,
you can do anything.
- You know what's good.
- It's basically Michelin
star at that point.
It is world-famous, so
the first time I cook,
it was at Mae Lynne's house.
And when you're cooking in a kitchen
that you're unfamiliar with,
with equipment that you don't know,
sometimes you have an
oven, or you don't know.
Like, with Japanese ovens,
especially the ones that aren't pre-built,
but the ones that you buy,
they say a temperature,
but the actual temperature
varies depending on what oven
and what brand you buy, right?
- That's true.
- Yeah, so I remember first
time I cooked this lasagna
for the public was that Mae Lynne's house.
- For the public.
- For the world.
- It's so world-famous-
- It's so world-famous.
- And I was like fucking sweating,
because weeks before I come to
Mae Lynne's house to cook it,
Mae Lynne was like,
"Can't wait for the world famous lasagna."
You know what?
I'm a give you a fucking Google review,
just to see if it is
actually world-famous.
I'm like, for fuck's sake,
man, this joke has gone
too far.
- The pressure.
- This is like cook for Gordon
Ramsey or something, right?
I feel like I'm part of
like, "Kitchen Nightmares"
or something right now.
So I'm cooking, I'm cooking
at Mae Lynne's house,
and it takes a while
to cook lasagna, right?
Because it's not like an easy dish.
You gotta cook the meat sauce,
you gotta layer it up,
and I wasn't familiar
with Mae Lynne's oven.
I'd cooked it a bunch
of times in my own oven,
and the first time I'm
cooking in Mae Lynne's oven.
- [Joey] Something that an
experienced chef would say.
- Yeah, I cook it in Mae Lynne's oven,
and unfortunately it wasn't hot enough.
Her oven didn't go hot enough.
- I liked it, I liked it.
- So you had a crispy lasagna?
- Yeah, so I cook it, and-
- A little al dente lasagna.
- That ain't al dente, that's crispy.
- What's the crispy one?
- Not al dente.
- What is al dente?
- I don't know.
I just say shit.
- Al dente means
to the bite, right?
So it's like just right softness,
I think.
- Yeah.
- Italian's, please confirm.
- Just say Italian words.
Like, just say them.
- It was definitely-
- Mama mia.
- Star of Italy.
(speakers laughing)
- I cook my lasagna mama mia.
- Yeah.
I mean, it wasn't fully cooked,
but the inside was definitely,
as Gordon Ramsey would say,
fucking raw.
(Garnt chuckling)
(Joey giggling)
- I mean, even if lasagna is like raw,
I'm like, this is still pretty
fucking good.
- It's a little,
I don't mind my lasagna a little crunchy.
- I mean, okay.
Connor enjoyed it, when I cooked some-
- I am not picky about my lasagna.
As long as you have all
the ingredients in there.
- I mean, the meat sauce is pretty good,
but Mae Lynne, nothing
goes past Mae Lynne.
She takes one bite and
she's like, "This is raw."
(Joey laughing)
"This is raw,"
and I'm like.
- Without the energy
of Gordon Ramsay.
- I'm just like, ah,
my cooking career is over
after one dish, you know?
This is it, this is it.
- [Joey] Big sad, big sad.
- I'm gonna put up my apron now,
I'm never gonna cook again.
- I'm just glad I got to
experience the "Ratatouille" movie,
in like, real time.
(Garnt laughing)
- And so that was the last
time I cooked a lasagna
for other people to taste.
(Joey laughing)
- So it actually deterred you?
- Yeah, yeah,
until, until,
until this housewarming party
where Sydney obviously invites,
you know, Sydney invites everyone.
And she sends people this menu as well,
things that we were going to cook, right?
And I'm just like, Sydney,
why would you do that?
And without my knowledge,
she said I would be cooking
the world-famous lasagna,
literally on the menu,
right?
- She was trying to
bring the old man out of retirement,
and try and get him back in the game.
- I mean, yeah.
I feel like a retired hero
or something, you know?
I'm just like Sydney-
- "I haven't done that in years."
- "I'm past my prime, now I can't do it.
I can't do it, Sydney.
Don't make me do it."
She's like, "Garnt, it's out.
Mae Lynne's coming, you
need to do it," right?
And so like, I'm like sweating now.
So a few days before the lasagna,
a few days before the housewarming,
I have a practice run.
- Oh my God.
- I actually got so
nervous that I'm just like,
I need to practice it.
My lasagna making skills
are a little rusty.
I need to get back on the pedestal,
see how it is done again.
And so, yeah, so-
- I need some oil in these bones.
- Yeah, so I did my lasagna
and Sydney loves it,
but I'm just like, I can do
better, I need to do better.
- Oh, God.
- I must confer the beyond.
- I make some mental notes before the day,
about the small changes I'm
going to make to the recipe,
like the small changes I'm gonna make
to the preparation and everything,
and so the day comes, and-
- It's like you're going
to like a bake-off.
- It is, it is.
- This ain't no joke.
- Like, imagine cooking
for Mae Lynne, you know,
but it's like-
- [Joey] I would never dare to-
- But it's your own personal recipe,
you know?
- Right, right.
Like, I think I would actually rather cook
for Gordon Ramsey at this point.
And so everyone comes, everyone comes,
and everyone has all the
different side dishes.
We have some meat boards,
we have some other things,
but the lasagna is the main dish,
and like, everyone's having a merry time.
I'm fuckin' sweating,
not just because of
the heat from the oven,
but I'm sweating out of nerves, man.
- You did look very nervous.
I do remember you looking really worried.
- I remember everyone coming in,
everyone coming in, Sydney
just greeting everyone,
and everyone's being so short.
And I was like, "Don't talk
to me, don't talk to me.
I'm making lasagna right
now, I'm making lasagna."
Connor's like, "Yo Garnt,
can I see your office?"
And I'm just like, "No Connor,
I'll show you after I
finish this fucking lasagna,
and then I'll be social and
then I'll be a good host.
But until the lasagna's
done, nothing is happening."
And so, and so I cook the lasagna.
It's an hour after Sydney had said
that the lasagna would be finished.
I don't care.
You can't rush perfection.
And then I finish it,
and then I take it out.
And then this is a
really weird experience.
People start crowding
around this lasagna, right?
- [Joey] Yeah, it's like, oh.
- Yeah, people started
crowding around this lasagna,
and I'm gonna say, it looked
fucking good, you know?
- [Joey] I mean, I saw the photos,
and it looked good.
- There's the thing
about lasagna, right?
Anyone who loves lasagna will understand,
is that the first spatula,
the first serving is always the best one.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, of course.
- Because the more people start
chunking out that lasagna,
the more sloppy it becomes.
- Yeah.
- Don't get me wrong,
it's not like lasagna is
the cleanest thing on earth,
but the first spatular
scoop is the best one.
You get the perfect ratio.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah,
'cause like, I needed to make sure
the cheese was like perfectly toasted,
'cause it can't be like raw cheese.
And the edges need to be
like a little bit crispy,
a little bit burned, right?
To me, that's a good lasagna.
- Yeah, of course, of course,
- You can't have like,
a completely raw, but not
too overburned lasagna.
And so I remember, I
remember finishing it.
Everyone was taking pictures.
I'm like, "Mae Lynne,
have the first taste."
(Joey wheezing)
The spotlight comes on.
The room is silent, right?
I give her the dish.
She takes one bite.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And it's just like the longest
fuckin' few seconds of my life, right?
I see her chewing this
lasagna, and I'm just like,
my life is like flashing
before my eyes right now.
And she's just like, "Oh
shit, you've leveled up."
I was...
(crew laughing)
(Joey singing)
- I can't explain the fucking euphoria
that just went over my body.
(Joey screaming)
- It was very good.
- It was literally that Japanese going...
(Garnt yelling)
(speakers laughing)
- It was good lasagna, it was very good,
I have to say, I can confirm.
It was great lasagna.
- It's like a lost "Food Wars" episode.
- It was.
- I'll be honest,
I don't remember any of the
other food that was there.
I remember the lasagna.
- Damn, must be good.
- And there was sandwiches.
There was
miniature sandwiches.
- Right, right, right.
- I don't know...
I know there was a menu,
but I can't remember
anything else on the menu.
- I mean,
what does it matter when you
had the world-famous lasagna?
- I just wanted Mae Lynne to
be really pretentious about it,
just be like,
"Al dente."
- I'm sure she had a childhood
flashback when she ate it.
- Maybe, I hope so.
But ever since that point, I'm just like,
"Damn, cooking's fun.
Cooking for other people can be fun."
- [Joey] Who would've thought.
- Yeah, so ever since
that, ever since then,
me and Sydney had been
cooking almost like every day.
So we used to like Uber
Eats almost every day,
and a big thing,
a big deal is because we
do have a dishwasher now,
so we don't have to wash
dishes ourselves anymore,
and that takes so much of the effort out
in the cooking process,
because I find cooking relaxing,
and I actually find it relaxing
to chop up the onions or chop
up the vegetables or whatever,
prepare the dish, cook the dish.
It's the clearing up that is
always putting me off cooking.
Ever since I've gotten the dishwasher,
cooking has actually been an
enjoyable experience for me.
- Yeah, I feel the more I'm doing it now.
Like, I used to fuckin' dread it.
Like, it was just stressful,
even following the menu or the recipe,
somehow I fucked it up in some regard.
I don't know, I was like,
I'm following the recipe, how
does this taste like shit?
- Yeah.
- But now the more I'm
like, (indistinct) cook,
and like, trying out
really easy pastas and like
something that is very difficult
to fuck up kind of thing.
I'm like, oh.
Wow.
It's kind of fun.
What the fuck?
Is this what it feels like
to be good at something?
- And it's just like, when you
see people eating your meal,
and they're just enjoying
it and feeling happy,
I'm like, oh, this is how chefs feel.
Oh my God.
I think I found like a
new hobby or something,
'cause it's genuinely a good feeling
to cook something that you're proud of,
and people also enjoy your cooking.
I get it now.
Mom, I get it, okay?
- I'm just saying.
- I get why you
was always like Eagle-eyed on me
whenever I'd eat any of your meals.
Okay, I get it now.
- I like cooking.
It's just a lot of work.
- It is.
- But also,
I'm also really bad with
portion control, right?
When I make food, I make food,
like a lot of food.
- Like a feast.
- I used to make a lot of lasagna,
but the problem was is that
I would then eat lasagna-
- You make a lasagna?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But is it world-famous?
- Nobody's had it.
- Well now I'm curious,
Connor, now I'm curious
how your lasagna is.
- We're about
to have a lasagna-off, aren't we?
- One time I made a
lasagna, and I was like,
oh, I totally forgot to
make the white sauce layer.
- Right.
- And I was like, why does
this taste like bricks?
- 'Cause it is.
- 'Cause there was like,
no white layers to balance
out the tomato shit.
But yeah, so I would have to make lasagna.
I always liked leftover
lasagna more than lasagna.
- Really?
- Something about
lasagna sometimes that like the next day,
when you heat it up, it's just perfect.
- 'Cause it's so thick, right?
- It's so thick, it kind of gets,
I don't know, try it, Garnt.
- It's like-
- I have tried it.
I like it.
- It's like
how leftover deep dish pizza tastes better
than the fresh deep dish pizza.
- Yeah, sometimes, I don't know why,
but at least the lasagna that I made.
I don't know, maybe it was like,
something I'm figmenting.
- Are you talking
about microwaved lasagna,
or do you just eat it straight
out with the fuckin' fridge?
- Properly made lasagna.
- And then I would like, put it back
in the oven.
- The next day, yeah.
- Oh, put it back in the oven?
- Yeah.
- Oh, okay.
- It just tastes good.
- I think maybe it's because like,
the juices are like,
seeping.
- Coagulated?
Are you talking about solid?
- It like seeps in, right?
- You could cut through it like a cake.
(Joey laughing)
- Whereas normal lasagna,
it goes fuckin' everywhere.
Which, don't get me wrong,
I generally prefer the normal lasagna,
but somehow when I used to make it
that for some reason I
liked it the day after more.
- No, I get that.
- I don't know why.
- Well, it's like curry, right?
Curry the day off to tastes
just as good as the day before.
- No, I've heard that.
That's like the biggest
fallacy I've ever heard,
'cause I've had day-old curry
that definitely doesn't
taste as good as like-
- What kind of curry though?
- Indian curry, right?
- Because I understand why.
- Indian curry may not be the same,
because with Japanese curry,
it's definitely better the day after.
- Yeah.
- Because it's taken the time
for everything to seep in.
- So are you,
sorry, go on.
- But like I was talking,
Japanese curry tastes
the same no matter what,
I feel.
- Yeah, that's true.
- I feel.
- You think so?
- I feel like I've never had bad curry,
but I've never had curry
that's made me like amazed
about how good it is.
- It is the most like, 6 out of 10
kind of.
- The special gourmet ones,
where they use like really rich stock,
and they have really
good quality beef pies.
- Yeah.
- At the end of the day, it's still
Japanese curry.
- It's still Japanese curry.
- Yeah, exactly.
- With pizza,
I was wondering about this,
because you know there's
people who are like purists,
that like stone-baked,
where is it from?
Napoli, Napoli?
- Napoli.
- Like, "That's the only style.
That's the correct style."
Which type of pizza is
your favorite style?
I was just curious,
because-
- Stone-baked.
- Stone-baked?
I do like stone-baked.
- Stone-baked is the only pizza
where I can eat the crust.
- Okay.
- Oh my God.
- Because, okay.
Because some like,
sourdough stone-baked pizza?
Oh my God, okay.
- [Joey] Yeah, it's good.
- I'm a crust hater,
but I'm a eat that fuckin' crust.
- I'm the same.
- And I'm gonna enjoy it,
okay?
- American pizza is the
best pizza, I think.
- Like, what kind of American pizza?
- Like a New York pizza,
that's like the best pizza.
- To be fair, New York pizza
is pretty fuckin' bomb.
- I think American style of
making pizza is the best way.
I love stone-baked, I
love stone-baked, right?
I love it, don't get me wrong.
But like, I don't know what
it is about American toppings.
- Italians,
I hear you Italians, I felt-
- Listen, listen, all right?
- A whole generation just like,
died right there.
- Here's my argument,
right?
The thing with stone-baked pizza
that sometimes kind of pisses me off,
why are they so goddamn
light with the toppings?
Like, they put like one pepperoni on it,
and call it a day, you know?
Which I get it, you don't
want to like submerge it.
But also, everything falls
off like, immediately as well,
so nothing stays in place,
and they put like, no fucking cheese on.
- Isn't that based off like the,
it's either the Napoli or the
other type of a Italian pizza.
But like, it's not supposed
to be a heavy meal.
It's supposed to be very,
very light.
- I love when
it's heavy.
- I don't know
which one it is.
- I love the heaviness of American pizza.
- Right, right.
Like it's all like a nice-
- By American pizza, what do you mean?
Because there's so many different types
of American pizza.
- The American style
of making pizza is like
the, from what I understand,
like New York where it's like-
- [Joey] Like Dominos.
- Yeah, it's like perfectly
constructed, right?
Where it's this slice that like,
is very solid on its own,
like when it's cut up,
nothing like falls off,
nothing like fuckin'
slips off or anything.
It's a nice, solid bit of pizza.
I love it.
Also, one thing I tried,
which I thought was gonna
be disgusting, right?
This is vile, I know it sounds gross.
Hear me out, all right?
I had this.
- Do you like the grease?
Do you like the grease?
- Yes, so...
- Hold on, hold on, hold on.
I'm listening, I'm listening.
- I tried the hot dog in the crust pizza,
and fucking I loved it.
- Oh, like a sausage.
- Like a hot dog in the
crust, I really enjoyed it.
- Do you like cheesy crust?
- Yes, but I liked the hot dog one more.
- Really?
- It's like an extra meal.
- But what if you put the
cheese inside of the hotdog,
and you put that in the crust?
- That's just not even a crust anymore.
Like whenever people say,
"But do you eat stuffed crust?
Stuffed crust is good."
Stuff crust is what you
eat when you're like,
when you don't wanna
actually eat crust, okay?
It's a mozzarella stick,
okay?
- Okay yeah, I know that.
- This is just a fucking hot dog, okay?
You're eating a pizza
with a hot dog at the end.
- I like hot dogs.
I like the hot dogs.
- That sounds amazing.
- I like the hot dog.
You can get it in Japan.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, Pizza Hut did it.
- Oh.
- You're not gonna pretend
that this is better
than stone-baked pizza, or
like fresh fuckin' pizza?
- Honestly, yes.
- Okay, but in Japan, though.
- No way.
No fucking way am I
listening to this right now.
- In Japan, there's two types
of pizza in Japan, right?
There's pizza, and then there's pizza.
All right, two different things.
You guys laugh, but it is true.
- We got like an hour
left on this recording,
can we order a Pizza Hut pizza
with sausage in the crust?
- I actually wanna try it.
- I'm just saying, we should do it.
We should all have a live reaction.
- Yeah.
- Why?
- One, because I wanna see your reaction.
- I want to see your reaction.
- I've had hotdog crust pizza.
It's a hot dog crust pizza.
- On camera?
Have you had it on camera?
- [Joey] I've never tried it.
- Yeah, I want to see Joey
try it.
- How have you never tried it?
- Because I barely eat cheesy crust.
I just want like, a regular crust.
- I'm pretty sure they have it, man,
I'm telling you.
- Why don't you
like cheesy crust?
- It's too heavy.
- And you want a hotdog crust?
- Honestly, it's like, it's so good.
It's like a very tight hot dog.
It's like wrapped around.
It's like a bite-sized hot dog.
- It's like a hotdog burrito.
- Bro, it's so good.
I hope they have it.
I need to check if they still have it.
- So in Japan, right?
There's two types of pizza, there's pizza,
which is like stuff like
Pizza Hut, Domino's,
American pizza basically.
- [Garnt] Right.
- And then this pizza,
which is the Italian pizza.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- So like if you ever go
to like an Italian-like
restaurant or whatever, or establishment,
you'll be able to know the difference
between like the Italian,
like stone-baked stuff that Garnt likes,
and then the American
stuff that Connor likes.
- Disgusting.
- At least Japan has
made a distinction being,
like, at least they're
not one of those countries
that are like, "All pizza is the same."
- Like I remember when I
first went to New York, right?
I had my first like New York pizza,
and the selling point
of this pizza was that
you could literally tilt-
- It's as big as your face.
- You could literally tilt the pizza,
and you could see the oil dripping off it,
and I'm just like, how
is this a selling point?
You're meant to make this appetizing.
It's just pure fat that's
like rolling off now.
- But I went to a place
in New York that was like,
I guess like kind of famous in New York.
I forgot what it was, but like,
they're famous for like
dabbing the oil off the pizza.
- [Joey] Off the pizza?
- So it's really, really,
it's a massive pizza,
but it's really thin and really light.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So like, I don't know about the full,
whole like, oil dripping off thing,
like if that was the selling point,
I wouldn't eat it.
- But the point is you're
still dabbing off the oil,
because there is so much oil on the pizza.
- Right, right.
- And to me, that's not appetizing.
I don't know.
Like when I see that much oil on anything,
that just, I don't wanna eat it, you know?
I can feel my arteries just clogging up
from eating this.
- As much as like,
there's a place called
Pizza Slice in Shibuya
that's really good, that
does a New York style pizza.
Fuckin' bomb.
I can only go there maybe
like once a month though,
because my God, after two slices,
I'm like about to explode.
- Look, I get it where, you know,
I get that it's a nice fast meal.
It feels good, it feels unhealthy.
But to say that it is better
than stone-baked pizza.
- It is.
- That's where I draw the line, man.
No fuckin' way.
- If I had to choose, oh God, so hard.
- I just liked pizza in general.
- It's all delicious.
- I'm not saying that
stone-baked is not delicious,
I'm not saying that New
York pizza is not delicious
as well in its own way
that I love.
- Because like,
both types of pizza have their benefits.
- Cause the only thing-
- One, it can be an everyday meal.
- The only pizza that I'd
say the Americans do the best
is Chicago pizza.
- The deep dish stuff, right?
- Deep dish stuff.
But like, that's like,
that's not even nowhere else even does it.
- That's a pie, that's a pie.
- No, no, yeah, exactly.
It's it's a pizza lasagna,
but it's a pizza lasagna.
That's what Chicago deep dish pizza is,
and that's why
it's fucking amazing.
- It's got these squared.
- This episode is sponsored by Honey.
- We all shop online.
We've established that by now.
We've all seen that
promo code field taunt us
at the checkout.
- Every time.
Every time, Connor.
- But thanks to Honey,
(Connor singing)
manually searching for coupon
codes is a thing of the past
because Honey is the
free browser extension
that scours the internet for promo codes,
and applies the best one
to find it to your cart.
Honey works with over
30,000 online stores.
They range from sites that
have tech, gaming products,
to a couple of fashion brands,
and even food delivery.
- Let me tell you how this works.
Imagine you're shopping one of your
favorite sites.
- I am.
- You're at the checkout once again,
and then the Honey button drops down,
and then all we have to
do is click apply coupons.
Wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons
it can find for that site,
and if Honey finds a working coupon,
you'll watch as the prices drop.
(Connor and Joey screaming)
Joey, what'd you save from Honey?
- So I bought a brand new
tripod for my brand new camera.
I saved the whopping $35.
- I didn't even know you could
save money on tripods, Joey.
- Oh darn, it's because
honey can save you money
on pretty much anything.
- By getting it, you'll
be doing yourself a solid
and also supporting this podcast.
So, what are you waiting for?
Get honey for free at
joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinhoney.com/trashtaste.
Joey with the outro.
- Back to the show.
- For me, there's something
about the fillingness
of an American pizza
style that I love so much.
- [Joey] Yeah, I get that.
- Like I love, I really, really miss
Domino's pizza in the UK.
It was so good.
I love that piece.
- What's different about it in the UK?
- I don't know.
I don't know why it's so good.
- I don't know either.
- I think it's just biased.
- I think it just tastes the same.
That's me.
- I've had Domino's around like,
lots of different places,
and they all kind of taste the same.
- I had Little Caesar's pizza in America.
- Right.
- And I thought it was delicious.
- The mini-pizzas?
- No, the big ones.
- Oh, the big ones.
- This was like $5 for like a large,
and everyone was saying like,
"Bro, it's like the worst pizza on earth."
- Yeah, it's not-
- I actually like, liked it.
I like oven pizza a lot.
- It's not really great.
I had it in America as well.
- I liked it.
I liked it.
- I'd much rather Domino's
than Little Caesars.
- I like Little Caesars.
And also-
- I'm just convinced you
don't have tastebuds.
(Joey laughing)
- The more you talk,
the more I'm just like-
- No, no, no, no, no.
Also, my enjoyment of it also increases
knowing that for all of
that for $5, that's insane.
What?
- That's got nothing to do
- With the taste.
- But the taste is good,
and it's only heightened by
the fact that it's simply $5
for this massive food.
Like this could feed the
entire fucking last supper,
this little Caesar's pizza.
- Yeah, because it's not that great.
That's why.
- That doesn't
effect the taste.
- No, it does.
We go to a place, right?
The price affects the
way you see the food.
It does.
- Yes, and that's exactly
why Little Caesars
tastes like $5 pizza,
and it's not that great.
You get a dollar slice in New York,
and it is foolish of me to act like
knowing it was $1 didn't
contribute to my enjoyment vessel.
- Yeah, of course,
but you don't go to a New
York pizza place and be like,
"I would like an exquisite
meal right now please, $1?
Oh, what a steal."
- Is it because stone-baked
pizzas are not big enough?
- That is one big factor.
- Is that it?
- Yeah.
- So, hypothetically,
if you found a restaurant
here in Japan, or wherever,
that does stone-baked sourdough pizza
but it was the size of a New York pizza.
- But also they skimp out on
the toppings a lot, right?
- Well, I mean,
in Japan, they definitely do.
But if you've had like
stone-baked in England?
Like in Europe?
- In Italy,
and a lot of the time they skimp out.
- [Joey] Really?
- I'm like, "You don't
put enough toppings on."
Like, the sauce is
generous enough, I'd say.
But like cheese?
Like, come on man.
- I had stone-baked in Italy,
and they stacked that shit.
- I haven't been to Italy, but like,
the best stone-baked pizza places I go to,
they don't skimp on the cheese.
They don't skimp on the toppings.
- 'Cause you're in like
a British version of it,
so they fix it.
- The one I had in
Northern Italy was packed.
- [Connor] Was it really?
- Yeah.
It was like-
- Every time I've had one in Italy,
it's been like, very lacking in toppings.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- I don't think you go
into the right places.
- [Connor] I don't know.
- Like as the person who is like
the biggest simp for bread,
how does that not play a factor
in how these pizzas taste?
- No, So that's more of a,
I would say stone-baked in many aspects.
in my mind, it's more
about enjoying the bread
than it is about the pizza.
Like, I don't even consider it-
- Right, right.
- Like to a point where I'm like-
- It's flavored bread.
- I'd rather just get like,
bread, like, at this point.
Just give me a real fuckin' pizza, bro.
If it doesn't give me like
five spots the next day,
it isn't a pizza.
I wanna be fucked up.
Fuck me up with this pizza.
- You know what?
You know what?
The board's right, British
people don't have taste.
- No.
It's confirmed.
- I'm team America with this one, man.
I'm American all the way on this one.
American pizza goes hard.
It doesn't-
- There's a time and a
place for an American pizza.
- Every time.
- Hands down.
- Every day.
- There is a time and a
place for American pizza,
but it is not the superior pizza.
- [Joey] It is not the superior-
- It's not the superior pizza.
- It is superior.
- America, I salute you with your pizza.
- [Joey] Okay then.
- Your pizza slaps.
Keep doing it.
- [Joey] Okay, let's see how,
okay, then question,
which one's better, Japanese
sushi or American sushi?
- I'ma head out.
(Garnt laughing)
Well no, obviously Japan does it better.
- Well then.
- [Connor] Sushi.
- Yeah.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- So like, if I was to
give you a choice of like,
just standard like regular
tuna that you get a like,
a composition here, or a California roll,
which one would you choose?
- But I feel like compare,
like I feel like the end of the day,
a pizza, a stone-baked pizza,
and a pizza are like the same shit, right?
- What you've said.
(Joey laughing)
- But, a sushi roll is not
even remotely like sushi.
Come on.
You cannot sit here me dead in the eye
and tell me that you think.
- Okay, Connor, what you've basically said
is basically like, oh yeah,
sweet and sour chicken
is the best Chinese food.
(Connor and Joey laughing)
You know?
- Orange chicken.
- Orange chicken is the best.
Chicken tikka masala is the
best Indian curry, in the world.
And I'm just like, no.
I am not going to stand here
and listen to this bullshit,
okay?
- I've had, okay right,
I've had both pizzas.
- I'm becoming in honorary
Italian for like a fuckin' day.
- I don't care.
- Just to call you
out on your fucking bullshit.
The rest of the episode.
- If I lose my Italian fan
base for this, so be it, right?
You guys have shit pizza
compared to the Americans.
Come on.
- Oh my God.
- I just can't get over the fact that-
- Let's trace it back to World War II.
I'm just kidding.
(speakers laughing)
It's like with sushi and stuff like that,
there's like a lot of the
sushi is not even close.
I don't even think that's-
- How is it not close?
- They use the same ingredients.
- No, it's not.
- Yeah.
- A lot of the time,
the ingredients aren't even similar,
I think.
- Everything inside
of a California roll, they
use in regular sushi here.
- Do they really?
- Just not together.
- What's in the California roll?
- What are the ingredients
of California roll?
- It's salmon.
- You sounded so confident.
- It's salmon, cucumber.
- Yeah.
- Does roll-
- But like, rolls in general are like
an American thing.
- So different.
- Yeah, so different from sushi.
I wouldn't say stone-baked is that far off
from normal pizza.
- But Japan has rolls as well.
- Do they really?
- Yeah.
- No,
but they don't have
the same kind of rolls.
- Not the same kinds-
- It's lot of fried shit, right?
- [Joey] No, no, no, no.
Nothing like that.
- From what I've seen,
Japanese rolls are just
like one fish in a roll,
and that's it.
- I feel like
this is a dumb argument,
but I'm ready to die for it.
- Okay.
- That's "Trash Taste" though, right?
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- It ain't "Trash Taste"
without a food argument.
- I just, I'm watching
a man commit suicide,
and I'm just like,
"All right, you can kinda,
you jump off the cliff."
- I think-
- Don't say I didn't try to like,
grab you and warn you that this is a cliff
you're jumping off of.
- I think a lot of the
viewers will agree with me
that American pizza is
better than Italian.
First of all, we have
an American audience.
- Yeah, and it's because I guarantee
that there are more Americans
watching this than Italians,
and there are more people who have been
to America than Italy.
- I've been to both.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- Still more pie.
- Actually, yes.
- [Crew Member] A California
roll is not Japanese.
- Yeah, I know.
- We know that.
- What are the ingredients?
- Is it the?
- [Crew Member] Imitation crab.
- Which they have.
Which they have.
- You don't get crab on
sushi normally though.
- Yeah.
- You don't really?
- Yeah, of course you do.
- Not that often.
- I get it all the time.
- Really, where?
- Yeah.
- In any sushi tray.
- You get the crab head in the thing,
but you never get like crab.
- You get crab on it, yeah.
- You can, yeah.
- Really, I've never seen this.
- This is the man who just said
that meat sushi didn't exist
even though he's had it, so I don't know.
(Garnt chuckling)
- To be fair, I still don't
view it when I go to get sushi.
- Not exactly the most
reliable narrator, this man.
- It doesn't matter.
America pizza's better than stone-baked.
I'll die on the hill.
- Oh my God.
- This is just like a bad
person making a good argument.
Like people just gonna disagree with me,
'cause I'm fuckin' dumb.
It's not a good argument.
- It's a great argument.
- It's not a good.
- It's quite in fact the opposite.
You're a good person with a shit argument.
- This is a preferential thing,
I just think the pizza's better.
It's not flat out being wrong.
- Look, I'm not saying
American pizza is bad.
- I love American pizza.
- This is not what we are,
arguing by the way.
- Both pizzas
are fantastic in their
own unique ways.
- But to act like
it is so far beyond
belief to it even insist
that American pizza could be interpreted
as better than stone-baked.
Like, that's just a wild claim.
It's not wild.
People like American pizza
more than stone-baked.
- [Joey] Because they've
never had stone-baked.
- They have had stone-baked.
- I want to see how many people.
- I think you'll be shocked
by the amount of viewers
that actually think American
is better than stone-baked.
- How many of our viewers
who have had both can agree with you,
and say that the American-
- Your head's in the clouds.
- Would you say Domino's is
better than stone-baked pizza?
- In my mind,
I would rather Domino's pizza
than a stone-baked pizza.
- What?
(Joey laughing)
- And I have seen, right?
I remember, I remember as well,
I felt so gratified like-
- Hey yo, give this man some taste buds.
- I felt so relieved,
which, who's that guy who
was like 1500 Netflix shows?
The, I think he's a chef
from, I think Japan,
but he's he's American.
- The bearded guy?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, I forgot his name.
- There was one scene, right?
Where he was doing a
whole thing about pizza,
and he went around reviewing
all different types of pizza.
And there was one scene where he's like,
"You know, at the end of the day though,
there's just something
about a Domino's pizza
that just go so hard."
And I was like, yes,
yes.
- That's probably a reason why
we don't remember his name.
- Pretending like Domino's pizza,
or these like fast food
pizza taste like shit,
you're just clowning.
- I never said that.
- We never said that.
- It's like saying a McDonald's burger
is better than like a
gourmet freshly made burger
at a burger joint, you know?
Like, yes, there's a place for it,
but to say that as better is like.
- I've had many burgers
where I would prefer
the McDonald's burger,
over said burger.
- Well yes, of course.
- Because a lot of the time
they're just like, yeah,
let's just get some like good beef.
Let's just like, not consider
the ratios or anything.
We should put like, shit on it.
Let's put like,
500 crumbs of bacon.
- What I'm saying,
the argument we're making
is think of the best burger
you've ever had that wasn't McDonald's,
and put that next to a McDonald's burger,
which one would you rather?
- But I've had
a lot of pizza in Italy
that wasn't stone-baked
that I think was much
better than stone-baked,
but I was more into it
than American style.
- I mean, it's like-
- It's like the heaviness of it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Stone-baked
isn't the only type of pizza.
But to me, definitely,
it is like the pinnacle.
I fucking love stone-baked.
- Fucking hell.
- [Joey] It's the best bread.
- You know what?
It's because it's like the best bread,
the best cheese.
- This is coming from a man
who can't appreciate the crust.
This comes with like,
I feel like you've
already tainted the pizza
with shit tasting crust.
- It's because
I don't eat the crust
that I can appreciate
a fucking good stone-baked,
because it's the only
pizza that I eat the crust,
okay?
- I just feel like
you have, like.
- It's like watching a
vegan eat a chicken wing.
It's like, oh my God, it's a monumental,
it must be really fucking good chicken.
- You don't even appreciate bread,
So how can you even have an
opinion on what's better pizza?
Like, you know what I mean?
Like, you don't have a core fundamental
of bread.
- No, no, no,
it's like, I don't
appreciate 90% of bread,
because to me, 90% of bread
tastes the fuckin' same,
you know?
But it's like.
- Okay,
I'ma have to stop you
right here, bro.
- You cannot say that.
- I was on your side until you said that.
- That's like me going,
"Bro, every fuckin' rice and noodles
is the fuckin' same, bro.
It's like, let's just get."
- Udon is exactly the same as fuckin'-
- Why is it no different
from instant noodles?
Bro, it's 90% the same.
- It's like 90% of the ramen noodles-
- I didn't think you could be
racist towards white people.
But in that moment, I
think you genuinely were.
I think that was actually racist
towards white people, bro.
- French people clutching
their baguettes right now.
- French folk? Germans
are losing it right now.
That's half of German food, man.
We got to do a "Trash Taste" special
where we just take Garnt
to a German bakery,
and he just he's like, what the fuck?
I didn't know you could have
15 different types of bread.
- Are you saying that a pretzel
tastes the same as a baguette?
- Is pretzel bread?
Oh.
- [Connor] What kind of?
Yes, it's bread.
What?
Not the little fuckin' hard
like, cookie-esque ones.
- Like pretzels.
- Like an actual pretzel.
- All right.
I'm gonna be honest.
Okay.
- What are you about to say?
- I'm gonna be honest.
A pretzel to me is just a salted baguette.
- No.
- That's what
it tastes like to me.
- No.
What?
- That's that's kind of
what it tastes like to me.
- What?
- Okay?
- Like, to me,
bread.
- Bro.
- Okay, to me, I can't eat bread.
- This is how World War III begins.
- To me, I can't eat bread
by itself a lot of times,
it needs to be flavored, okay?
It needs to have some butter on it.
Like, for example, a baguette,
I need some butter with that baguette.
I love the times, okay?
Pretzels, they have salt, okay?
- No, you can't just eat a baguette.
Like, a good baguette?
- With butter?
- No, just a baguette.
- [Joey] Just eat it by itself.
- I can't fuckin' eat
a baguette by itself.
That's just like-
- You just blew off all
of your fuckin' audience
this is episode, Garnt.
You like, won the Italians,
and then throw them away.
What the fuck, Garnt?
They're furious.
- No, no, no, no, no-
- Even the Italians are doing this right.
- We need to on a European tour,
fuckin' actually have-
- Bye-bye Europe.
- With the crust,
you're not eating, you
know, it's not like,
you have the pizza pie with the cheese,
and the toppings and everything,
and then you have the crust part, right?
That's a very small ratio
to the whole pizza itself.
I can't eat a pizza-sized
crust no matter how good
the fuckin' stone-baked crust is.
- I can just chow down
on a whole baguette,
like straight down,
when it's good quality?
Like, I don't even need-
- Pretzel as well?
Like, if it's lightly salted,
don't even don't even need
mustard with that.
- I don't think
you've had good bread, Garnt,
genuinely.
- Yeah.
- I think you, if you had fresh bread,
like good bread, I think
you'd change your mind.
- Fresh bread is good, but like-
- What like fuckin' tesco bread?
- No, no, no, no, I've had fresh bread,
but bread to me is-
- What fresh bread?
I'm skeptical now,
where have you had this fresh bread?
- Okay, so you-
- You had fresh bread yesterday.
- [Garnt] That was fuckin' great.
Could I eat more than just
the slice that we got?
No.
- [Joey] What?
- That was too much, and with the slice?
You know, I fuckin'-
- I could have destroyed that whole plate.
- No, fuck no.
- Yeah, I coulda
had that bread.
- That's way to good.
- Every time I go to
an Italian restaurant in America-
- I've had many meals where
I have enjoyed the bread,
like an amount where honestly,
if the rest of my food didn't
come out, I would be happy.
- Yeah, every time I go to an
Italian restaurant in America,
and they always give
you the plate of bread.
I'm just like more, I need more.
This is not gonna be enough.
- Bread, to me, is a starter.
It is a starter.
It is not the meal.
You can't just have bread as a meal.
- [Joey] This man would not
have survived.
- I don't know who
I'm offending wit this take right now,
but to me.
- The entire middle ages.
- [Joey] Peasants in the 1800's.
- I can't just have like,
pure bread as a meal.
I'm pretty sure like-
- If you were born in
the 1700's in Europe,
you would be so dead.
- [Connor] I didn't think
we're gonna have another
food episode.
- They're like, "Bread?
For dinner?"
- I feel like, right,
you guys may be such a
big deal fuckin' deal
about this pizza thing
that I didn't think it was a big deal.
- No one means this shit.
- And this man walks in here being like,
"Bread is shit," like, straight up.
Like, what?
You don't even have like a
gluten allergy or something,
or some shit like that to hide behind.
- I didn't say bread was shit.
I said, "Bread is not a meal."
- You said "90% of bread,"
and I quote, "tastes the same."
(Connor sighing)
- Okay, I'm gonna go back
on that statement, okay?
- You better recant
that statement.
- 90% of bread
does not taste the same.
- How much percent?
How much percent?
- But I mean like-
- Grade 87%.
- Name a percent, Garnt.
- Okay, with bread, I
can't have bread as a meal.
That's like having pure rice as a meal,
okay?
- No.
- As an Asian, I can't
just have a rice as a meal.
I know people can just
have rice as a meal,
but you need to fucking
seasoning on the rice.
- It's so different.
- You need some flavoring.
You need something to go with the rice.
- I can have rice as a meal.
- [Connor] I know you can, but now-
- No, I know you can, but would you?
- Bread doesn't fill
the same role as rice.
- It literally does.
- No, it doesn't.
- No it doesn't, it doesn't.
- Yeah, I mean like,
I'll completely disagree that
all bread tastes the same
or whatever, but I can agree
that all rice tastes the same.
- Yes, okay.
I would say most rice-
- Really?
- Yeah.
That is...
- There is different types of rice, right?
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But, like rice.
- Obviously, I can tell
the difference between like Japanese rice,
and like saffron rice.
- But there's like, rice pudding
and all that shit as well
that's all nonsense, but.
- Is rice pudding even rice
at that point?
- I think
comparing the roles that
bread and rice fill is like,
no, it's completely different.
It's totally different.
- I can't believe you're Japanese, Joey,
and you're going to say that
all rice tastes the same,
where a huge part of
Japanese cuisine is like,
the subtle differences
in how the rice tastes.
- Hey yo, that's all bullshit there.
That's all marketing.
It's all marketing, dude.
- [Connor] I will agree with-
- Every time you go to a
fuckin' Dukan or anything,
and you get like the massive meal,
and they bring out the bowl of rice,
and they're like, this
is the top branded rice
of this prefecture, and I take a bite,
and I'm like, "Bro, this tastes
exactly the same."
- You are wrong.
It does not taste
the same.
- It tastes exactly the same.
- You're chowing down on it
too fucking fast to appreciate
the subtle fuckin' taste.
- It's literally just carbs.
It's just...
- That's what bread is.
That's what bread is.
- No, no, no, no.
- Literally just carbs.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- It's literally just carbs.
- It's so much more than that,
whereas rice is just pure starch, right?
Bread has so much more that goes
into making a good bread, right?
You've got all the different ingredients,
that go into making it.
- I'm afraid to say
anything anymore.
- Rice is just like a hundred
percent starch, right?
- Because there is subtle
differences into how to cook rice.
(Garnt chuckles)
- No, no, no, but like,
if we brought out two
bowls of rice, right?
And one was from like
fuckin' Akita prefecture.
- You wouldn't tell
the difference.
- And another one
from another prefecture,
I could not tell you
the fuckin' difference.
- No, it's not just
about the type of rice.
It's how you cook it as
well, which is why sushi rice
tastes different depending on
which sushi place you go to,
because-
- Sushi rice tastes different
because it's got vinegar in it.
- It's cooked with vinegar.
It's seasoned with vinegar,
right?
- Yeah, obviously.
- Yeah, so it's part
of the cooking process.
- But if there was two
bowls of sushi rice,
one from Akita and one from Nagano,
you can't tell the difference.
- That's like saying you
have two pieces of bread
were cooked exactly the same,
then they taste the
same, which they would,
because they're cooked
exactly the same way.
That's-
(Joey cackling)
- I feel like both of these
arguments are fucking stupid.
- Yeah, they are.
- I'm just trying
to make sense-
- I just realized.
- Of both arguments here,
and I'm losing my mind.
- I just realized.
- I'm losing my mind to this
fuckin' conversation now.
- I think I do agree that
rice is less, what's the word?
- [Joey] Diverse.
- [Connor] Yeah, diverse than bread.
Like, the bread has way too many.
- I'm saying, like my core argument
is that I can't eat bread as a meal.
It's the same way as
eating rice as a meal.
- I genuinely believe you
haven't had good bread,
like genuinely.
- I have had good bread.
- I don't think you have.
- Was the bread we had yesterday good?
- That was, even compared to German bread,
that's mid.
- Was it good bread yesterday?
- I thought was kind of good.
(speakers laughing)
- It was good,
it was good, right?
Don't get me wrong, it was good bread,
but, I'm telling you, man.
I been to-
- I've never been to Germany,
so I don't know, like-
- Oh yeah, I spent a lot
of my childhood in Germany,
and I can tell you,
man, it's fuckin' good.
It's so good.
- I bet.
- Every time we go a German
restaurant, it's like, amazing.
- Because it's like,
the only thing that
Germany does well, right?
Is the three foods that
Germany specialize in,
beer, which is food there.
It's not a drink, it's a food.
You have bread, and then you have meat.
The meat is good, right?
- Sausages.
- Right, right.
Fucking amazing, right?
- Great sausages.
- There's a reason why
they stick to three things,
'cause they fucking do it amazing.
The bread is insane.
Everyone's like French baguettes.
No, like French baguettes
can fuck themselves, bro.
German bread is like
20,000 light years ahead.
- Right.
- Of it.
It's not even comparable.
- So could you, what if you
could have bread as a meal,
why don't you then?
- You're saying you want variation, right?
You want like, different things.
Like, if you just have bread every,
yeah, you will get bored,
but I can easily have bread
occasionally as a full meal
if I needed to.
- Really?
- If it was German bread,
yeah, no qualms about it.
- [Joey] Yeah, if it was German bread,
I guess.
- Like a fresh pretzel?
- Yeah, if you give me like
three pretzels just by itself,
not like no mustard or anything.
- Give me a beer too?
- Give me a beer with that, oh.
- I need a stronger taste than just bread.
- Because you haven't had good bread.
- You haven't had a good-
- I have had good bread.
No matter how good the bread is,
I can't eat a bread as an entire meal.
- We're going to Germany.
- You know?
- Go to Germany, get a good pretzel.
- I can appreciate good bread,
I can appreciate a good slice
before the actual meal comes up,
before the actual serving
of whatever dish I've ordered comes out,
you know, a bread is a good starter,
gets the pallet going,
but can I eat an entire?
If I go to a restaurant and I'm like.
- You're lucky we have a
Russian, not a German dub.
I'll tell you that, Garnt.
- "Waiter, I would like to
order an entire plate of bread,
and nothing else."
I'm just like, no, I can't do that.
- That's why you go to the bakery.
You don't go to the restaurant for
a piece of bread.
- Yeah.
There's a big bakery that
serves exclusively bread.
- Can I get like, bacon there too?
(speakers laughing)
Like, cut out the middleman, I don't know.
- It's like, made for people
who want bread as a meal,
perhaps, you know?
- Oh my God.
Oh my fucking God.
- You're exhausted now, Garnt?
- I am exhausted.
- I can't wait for this fucking
hotdog crust to turn up.
- [Joey] I wanna try this shit, dude.
- It's so good.
- I really want to
try this shit.
This episode is sponsored by Bokksu.
- Ho, ho, ho, merry
Bokksu Christmas, gamers.
Here's one for you, Joey.
Here's one for you, Garnt.
Oh my God, it truly is a
magical time to be alive.
- But Santa, could you explain
to us what these boxes are?
- Why yes, of course Joey, I can.
Bokksu is a monthly snack
box subscription service
that delivers original assortments
of premium Japanese
snacks and tea pairings.
- [Joey] Bokksu makes such
a perfect and memorable gift
for anyone in your life who appreciates
Japanese snacks and culture,
especially during a time where people
aren't able to travel as
easy as they would like.
- And something special
for all the amazing Bokksu
customers this holiday season.
- Tell me.
- They will get
free tickets to Japan, maybe.
- Are you serious?
- Maybe.
Bokksu is was having a
giveaway where one lucky winner
will win a free pair of tickets to Japan,
and anyone who is subscribed
before December 31st
is automatically entered.
Link's in description down below,
so you can check out
the terms of conditions,
and other methods of entry.
- Gentlemen, do you like wood?
- I do.
- Because here's a
wooden kitty bako Bokksu
just for you guys.
- Oh my God.
- Look at that.
Look how aesthetic this is.
(Connor shouting)
From now until December 30th,
you can receive your Bokksu,
and a special kitty baku wooden
box for an additional $50.
- So use that code
trashtest10 and the link
in the description
below to become eligible
to win the giveaway by
subscribing to Bokksu.
The code will get you 10%
off your subscription,
don't miss out on this
unique opportunity available
for anyone who subscribes
until December 31st.
So what are you waiting for?
Get yourself or a special
loved one a cute bako Bokksu,
and check out the link for a chance
to win a free trip to Japan.
- Back to the episode.
- [Sydney] Also, I just wanna say,
Garnt, that you said every beer,
or not beer, bread,
where you make it, it'll taste the same,
even if it has the ingredients.
Actually, it's been
proven that when an air,
like bread rises, the air surrounding it,
depending on the region,
completely changes the taste.
(Connor mockingly singing)
So shut the hell up.
(Connor laughing)
- Sydney.
- Can we put
this in the episode?
- Sydney,
you're meant to be on my side.
- [Sydney] No.
- Sydney, Sydney.
- Put it in, Bruda.
- [Sydney] And then you put in-
- Justice has been served.
- I can't believe I've
been betrayed by this.
(Joey laughing)
Sydney, we're meant to be a fuckin' team.
- Top 10 anime betrayals.
- [Sydney] No, because
you're also saying like,
you guys are say like
rice tastes the same,
like what kind of fucking like, honestly?
- No, rice does taste the same.
- Rice does taste the same.
- It doesn't taste the same.
- [Sydney] The complete difference between
Thai rice, Japanese rice.
- No, no, no, no.
- Thank you.
- But all
Japanese rice tastes the same.
- No, but all rice does
not taste the same.
- Yeah, it does.
All Japanese rice tastes the same.
- Yeah.
- No, all Japanese rice tastes the same.
You guys are fooling yourselves.
It all tastes the same.
It's all a marketing ploy.
It's all a marketing ploy,
don't believe that shit when
they tell you at the rural con.
They could be giving
you fuckin' hundred yen,
like microwave packaged
rice for all I care.
- Yeah, but while we're
waiting for the hotdog crust,
I do have a story.
- Go on.
- That finishes the lasagna
arc, lasagna story arc.
Well, it's not even like a,
it's like a side story now.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So after our housewarming party,
we got a pretty merry,
and there was one thing I
had forgotten about Japan,
because in my previous place,
I lived on like a high enough floor
that I didn't need to worry
about bugs or wildlife
or that kind of thing,
because nothing could
ever reach the top floor
of my apartment at the time.
- Oh.
- So I forgot that Japan
has cockroaches, right?
- They sure do, guys.
Most countries do.
- I had completely forgotten
that Japan had cockroaches, right?
And what we found out
was during the party,
we didn't close one of our windows fully.
So the window was slightly ajar,
and we had left the food out,
because unlike in Thailand
where we were taught
to clean up everything every day,
because cockroaches can come,
living in a house,
we had forgotten that cockroaches can come
because we are living on the bottom floor,
where a lot of cockroaches
are, unfortunately.
I mean, it's a pretty new house,
so we didn't have to
worry about that before.
And I didn't notice this,
or I didn't know this
until me and Sydney were
having dinner the next day,
we'd cooked a nice meal,
because Sydney had cooked a nice meal,
and we were enjoying this
curry that she had cooked.
And we were like chowing down,
and then I look over, and
in the corner of my eye,
I see a black speck move about, all right?
And I move over and I look over,
and there's a fat fucking cockroach.
- How fat are we talking?
- It's about that size.
- [Joey] That's pretty,
that's a decent size.
- It's a decent sized
cockroach.
- Just moved in.
- Yeah, I had just moved in,
and I literally got PTSD,
because if you don't remember,
I had had a previous experience
with a cockroach in Thailand.
- [Joey] The famous cockroach story?
- If you wanna check that out,
there's a clip where I tell the story,
but I had had a previous
experience in Thailand
with a cockroach,
and it wasn't a pleasant
experience at all.
And I remember seeing this cockroach,
and Sydney was like, chatting away to me,
and she was like, "Garnt...Garnt?"
And I just, like, I was just silent.
I was just staring at this cockroach.
(Connor singing suspensefully)
And then
she like starts getting angry,
"Garnt, listen to me."
And she says that, and
then she looks over,
and then we're just
both staring in silence.
And then it's as if the cockroach knew
that we were looking at it.
It was flexing, because as
soon as Sydney looks over,
it just crawls away into
the air conditioning
in one of the holes,
and it just disappears.
And me and Sydney are just like,
"Fuck.
How do we burn this entire house down?
We can't burn this entire house down.
We just moved into this place," right?
- The cockroach literally
did an understandable,
"Have a nice day," to you,
just going off.
- And me and Sidney were
just sitting here in silence.
We were like war veterans, right?
Because we were just like,
we literally escaped-
- Not this again.
- We literally escaped this country,
we literally escaped Thailand
so we didn't have to
experience this again.
And here we are moved into our new place,
where we've been here for like a month,
and we have a single
cockroach in our house.
Fuck, what do we do?
So we sit there for
about an hour being like,
well, do we move out again?
Is that a viable option?
Like, what does the contract say, right?
And then eventually I'm just like,
I start going on Amazon and I buy like,
every cockroach related product I can find
in terms of like, cockroach
traps, cockroach sprays,
even though I've had previous experience
with cockroach sprays.
- [Joey] No, spray never works.
- I start reading-
- Sometimes.
Some of the fuckers are
built like brick stone.
- If Terraformers has taught us anything,
that shit don't work.
- Yes.
- They are invincible.
- Yeah, so like I started doing research
about Japanese cockroaches,
and if sprays actually work,
or if traps actually works,
because my experience with
cockroaches in Thailand
is that sprays don't work at fuckin' all,
and it can actually make
the situation worse.
- They just like, scream.
- Yeah, they just-
(Connor screeching)
- They just scream.
- [Joey] They go beserk mode.
- Yeah, and so that was,
so I order everything,
and I just try to forget
about the cockroach,
but like that night,
me and Sydney slept
with like one eye open.
Like we couldn't sleep that night,
'cause we were just like, how can we sleep
knowing that there is a
fucking cockroach downstairs?
What happens if I go to
the toilet, and I see it?
Well, I just hear a
scuffling about, right?
- [Joey] In the dark, right?
- Yeah, so in the dark.
So, we finally go to sleep,
and then first thing in the morning
I go downstairs to go to my office,
because my office is on the bottom floor,
and my living room and dining
room is on the second floor.
And I go downstairs, and what do I see?
It's the fucker.
It's right in the center
of my living room.
- It's got a lot of balls.
- It has got a lot of balls.
- Right on the kitchen.
- And I fuckin' freeze up.
I'm just like, fuck.
How do I get rid of this cockroach?
What do I do now?
I don't have my spray.
I don't, like, I don't know.
I'm kind of scared that
it's just gonna run off,
maybe it's gonna fly, and
like hit me in the face again,
and like, maybe it's gonna
be a similar experience
to what had happened in Thailand.
- I'm getting out the shoe.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- I'm getting out the shoe.
- And I'm just like,
(Connor imitating whip)
- It's that spirit you've got.
- I'm like, looking around.
What do I do?
Do I try and kill it?
Do I chase it away?
What do I do?
And then I'm trying to
ninja my way down, right?
And as soon as I try to do that,
it sees me, and then it
starts running, right?
It starts running.
And then I look at it, and I realize,
wait a minute, it's
running so fuckin' slowly,
because my experience was
with Thailand cockroach
is that they're like fuckin' Sonic.
They're like fuckin'
speedy motherfucker's.
This cockroach was running at full speed,
and it was just running like this.
And I'm like,
and then I like, I corner
it so it runs the other way,
'cause I'm still afraid that he can fly,
and I chase it towards the stairs, right?
And I assume that it's just
gonna get to the stairs,
and fly off.
It goes to the edge of the stairs, right?
And this stupid motherfucker, right?
It tries to go on the side of the stairs,
and it just drops, right?
It just drops, right?
And I'm just like, wait a minute,
these fuckers can't fly.
They can't fly, and they're slow as fuck.
And then suddenly I'm like,
I'm starting to feel myself.
I'm like, all right, all right,
maybe I got a chance here.
Maybe I don't need the cockroach spray.
I can get rid of this by myself.
So eventually the cockroach, right now,
is on the bottom floor,
so it's not even flying.
It didn't even like fly down,
It just walked, stumbled down,
like, landed on his back,
like, went downstairs, and
it kept going downstairs.
So, I run down the stairs
and I go into my office,
and I try to grab the
closest thing I could find
to fuckin' slam this thing, right?
And so the closest thing
I could find in this rush
happened to be a mouse pad,
a booby mouse pad, right?
- Garnt, what is that gonna do?
- [Joey] Why?
- You literally could
have got anything else.
- I think your fist would have been
more accurate.
- 'Cause I
didn't wanna, like,
I didn't wanna stain myself, okay?
So the closest-
- You're gonna stain
the booby mouse pad?
- Yeah, yeah, okay.
Weebs are crying right now.
It was the fastest thing I could find
in the rush.
- Fuck off,
was this the fastest thing you could find.
- Do you just have booby
mouse pads on your floor?
- Because I was looking for something,
like a shoe or something,
but everything in my office,
like I can't grab-
- Isn't your office right next
to where you keep your shoes?
So my shoes were in the cupboard, right?
- What about the slam dunk shoes?
(speakers laughing)
- I am not going to use
my fuckin' slam dunkers.
- Slam dunk.
- So it was like most of the
things in my office are figures
or most of the things I see like figures,
or like glass, or like solid shit.
So the only thing that I felt that
was the closest thing-
- Had elasticity?
- Yeah, elasticity,
with this thing I could slam this thing
without having to worry about it braking,
happened to be the booby mousepad, right?
- What's wrong with you guys?
Where was that?
- I wasn't thinking, okay?
- There's nothing else in your room?
- Is this the domestic
girlfriend one that you got?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Oh, no.
- Okay, so this is me-
- A fuckin' signed
piece of memorabilia.
- It wasn't signed, it wasn't signed.
I have my signed piece of memorabilia.
- [Joey] It was the worst girl.
- Yeah.
- So, okay,
so this was just like,
I explained this, like I
thought about this consciously,
no, I just ran in my room just
like, grabbed this mouse pad.
That was the closest thing,
and just ran back out,
and by instincts, or
maybe not by instinct,
so I grabbed like the booby
side of things, right?
I grabbed the tit side of things, right?
But like, this mousepad is like,
you've felt a booby mousepad.
- It's flimsy,
but it still has some weight to it, right?
So it's not exactly like
I'm hitting it with paper,
it has a little bit of weight,
but it's like slapping someone like that.
- I'd love to see how you picked this up,
and you're like, "Yes, this
is the weapon, my Lord."
God sent like the fucking
gladiator stadium, like guns.
You may choose a weapon of your choice.
- [Joey] Picks up a rock.
- Picks up the booby mousepad.
"I'm ready."
- Look, I had picked it up.
I'd committed to it,
because I was scared that
I would run back out,
and the cockroach would be gone,
but thankfully I ran back
out, it was still there.
I'm like, great.
I fuckin' wham it once, okay?
We're at full strength, slap
it, doesn't do anything.
- Well, yeah.
- That makes it like an air cannon.
- Yeah,
so I'm just like, wham
it once, didn't work.
Wham it twice, didn't work.
So I'm just fuckin'...
(Garnt huffing)
Like...
- Like fuckin' Quentin Tarantino scene.
- Honestly.
It was like a scene from a
gangster movie or something,
instead I don't have a hammer,
I'm not bashing someone's head in,
I'm bashing this fucking cockroach in.
- With a booby.
- With a booby mousepad,
and like this thing, okay.
So I hit it, it falls
over, runs back again,
flips over, runs back again.
- We're fucking you now.
- But after about five slams,
it starts slowing down.
This thing was like fucking boss battle,
and it had a fucking health bar.
I could see his health
bar twitting down, right?
Sydney's like, "Garnt,
what's going on? Garnt?"
I don't say anything.
I need to concentrate on kicking-
- A boss battle.
- All I hear is the boss battle.
- All I hear is the fucking
"Dark Souls" boss battle music.
I go for it for another three times.
It's like, crawling now, but I
still can't do the finishing,
like I still can't deal
the finishing blow.
So I'm just like, finally,
after it starts crawling,
I start using my head.
I'm like, wait a minute,
this isn't the heavy side.
- I thought you meant literally like.
(speakers laughing)
What's harder than a booby mouse pad?
- I was like, wait a minute,
this isn't the heavy side.
So I'm like, all right, I'm
gonna do the finishing move.
I turn the mouse pad over
so it's booby side up.
This is where all the weight is, right?
I go for one more, fuckin' wham.
Direct hit, one-hit
kill, it is dead, right?
It is-
- He literally went from like,
he went from dual blade to a broad sword.
- I can't believe you're
framing this story
like some kind of victory.
It's sounds like the most
pathetic thing I've ever heard.
- Because when it's like,
when I saw it belly up, right?
I literally was panting, right?
- That's the soft spot.
- I was like...
(Garnt panting)
Sydney runs down, right?
She's like panicking, 'cause
she thought I just fell down
the fuckin' stairs or something,
because all she heard
was like, wham, wham,
and me just heavy breathing.
And all Sydney witnesses is just me
standing over the dead
corpse of this cockroach
with a booby mousepad in hand,
and I'm just like, in my mind,
I was like, "Do you see what you get?
Do you see what you get if
you mess with the warrior?"
So like, that's how I felt.
I'd never felt so much
adrenaline-
- What?
- Should hold up the mouse and be like.
(speakers screaming)
(Garnt laughing)
- I just wanna know why
was the cockroach, like,
I don't think I've ever heard
of a cockroach be that slow.
Maybe it ate too much lasagna.
- I've seen some.
There are some slow cockroaches.
- It ate the lasagna, probably.
- We don't know.
- I was like, oh fuck, I'm so full,
I'm just gonna stop.
- I'm gonna take my time.
Nice walking.
- Yeah.
- But that means you probably have more.
- Huh?
- That means you probably have more.
- No, I mean, we already saw
one, and we've only seen-
- Saw one.
- You only saw one, but you
know these sneaky motherfuckers
probably created a colony.
- We've got a load of traps
out just in case, you know?
- I've been dealing with a pest of my own.
- What?
- That sounds like I gonna
say like Garnt or something.
- Yeah.
- Well, true, but.
Fucking pigeons keep
shitting on my balcony.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I put the grass down.
They keep shitting on the grass.
Do you know how hard it
is to clean fake grass?
- That's so weird, 'cause
you've seen my balcony.
- Yes, I have.
I was gonna ask, how do you
not get pigeons shitting
on your balcony?
- Never.
- They come here, they chill there.
I'll literally, I'll
clean it all up, right?
It'll take like 30 minutes
to clean all this shit up.
There's so much crap.
- The only place actually
that I get pigeons
is the window in my office,
which is on the edge of the building.
- I think, because there's
like, my balcony is inward,
so it's like there's no wind or anything.
- Right, right.
- So I think it's like
nice and cozy for them,
'cause they always go for the corner top,
like they nestle
in the corner.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And they shit on this
thing relentlessly.
I literally clean it, and
I'll come back the next day,
and they'd be like 15 poops.
(Joey giggling)
And it's annoying', cause
it's like solidifies.
- You need to have something
to like, anti-pigeon.
- So now I've started having to,
I've gone through like
every method in the book.
I've got reflective shit
all over my balcony now.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- It's just everywhere.
- Hanging up CDs?
- Yeah, like stuff that
reflects, and so far, so far-
- [Joey] It's working?
- No poop.
- [Joey] Oh, that's good.
- So I'm hoping that I
don't get any more poop.
- God, just remembering that story
is just getting me ugly man, sorry.
- I didn't realize how relentless
these pigeons could be.
- Right.
- And they're so noisy too.
- Yeah, they are.
- I'll be sleeping.
I've got a PTSD, I'll hear the...
(Connor trilling)
And I'm like, "Fuck, get
out of here you damn kids."
- Pulls out the shotgun.
"Half my life."
- I get Garnt's M-16 from the figure rack,
so my, "Who wants some freedom?"
(Joey trilling)
- Why didn't you use the
M-16 on the cockroach?
- The M-16 is here.
- Oh, should take it home, shouldn't you?
- If we ever get a cockroach,
we'll win.
- Picks up cigarette.
- Pull out the big guns.
- With the cigarette in his mouth.
- Yeah.
- M-16 resting on his shoulder.
- I dare you.
I dare you to come.
- Take another bottle of zen,
cockroach, I dare you.
- No, no, no, no, because
after we killed it,
or after I killed it, you know?
- We? We?
- There's no we thing,
don't even go there.
- [Joey] Our victory.
- After I killed it,
after I successfully slayed
this fuckin' demon, then-
- Could probably hear fuckin' Lisa
playing in the background.
(Connor singing)
- Yeah.
- So after I slay this demon,
we got the brush out.
We sweep it away, right?
So I take it outside, lay it out.
Turns out the boss had a second phase.
It fucking gets up again, right?
I saw it scurry, and then-
- Second phase.
- All the old classic play at the end,
old classic.
- It's so weird, because
when we were sweeping in,
no movement, fucking dead.
Soon as it goes outside.
- That's a pro right there.
- Soon as it goes outside, turns
over, start scuttling away.
So I had fuckin' hit
it again, hit it again.
- With what?
- With the broom,
With the broom, right?
- But if it's outside, then
just leave it, all right?
- You know, no.
It's not about,
it's about sending a message.
- [Joey] You did send a message, inside.
- What if the kids are watching,
outside?
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's actually true.
- Yeah, but then eventually I'm just like,
fuck it, you know?
I'm gonna let this one go.
I'll be like, "Tell your friends,
tell your friends what happens
if you enter this house,"
you know?
- Come again,
I dare you.
(Garnt laughing)
Come again.
- And that was how Garnt
became a local hero.
- [Joey] Yeah, exactly.
All right.
The hot dog pizza has arrived.
- Do we know how much it
was, do you have a receipt?
- [Crew Member] About 22 hundred.
- Fuck me man.
- 22 bucks.
- Oh my God.
- For pizza this size?
- Look at this.
- It looks delicious, though.
- Oh, it's 50 off though.
This was $20.
- [Joey] Thanks Japan.
- Thank you.
- What a joke.
Look at that.
- Oh my God.
It's like actual, like, sausages.
- [Connor] Yeah, bro.
Dig in.
- All right.
- Dig in, y'all.
- What kind of pizza is it?
- Just a normal Margherita,
or no, it looks at pepperoni.
Yeah, give me a slice.
Go on.
- You're not gonna tell me
that this is better than the stone-baked.
- Oh yeah, this is, bro.
Look at the size.
- Well, okay,
to be fair-
- Oh, look how
moist that cardboard is.
- I'm not a massive
fan of Pizza Hut pizza in Japan.
- No, the Pizza Hut,
this one in Japan is weak, bro.
- Yeah.
It's not great, but.
I am curious to see how this...
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- How the sausage is gonna fair.
- That's pretty good, actually.
- [Joey] Yeah?
- I mean, pizza is pizza,
so it's gonna taste good no matter what.
- I just love that thick,
cheesy taste, you know?
- I love thick bread.
- I like how we're just eating.
(Garnt laughing)
- Audio-only listeners, I apologize.
- What point were we
trying to prove again?
- The hotdog.
I mean, when you get to it, try it.
- Okay.
- And then wrap it up a little bit,
get some sauce.
- Can I just eat it first?
- No.
- I feel like it's gonna taste less good
than the pizza side.
I've gotta have some sauce
left, some cheese on it?
(relaxing music)
(Joey chuckles)
- Such a weird pause.
- It's a hot dog.
- [Connor] I love it.
(relaxing music)
- Okay, I fuck with this.
- Right, isn't it good?
- It's weirdly good.
- [Connor] Right?
- I mean, I've had this before.
- It shouldn't be this good.
- Like, I normally get dip as well.
- Yeah.
- Is this better than stuffed crust?
- Yeah, I think so.
- I think it's better than stuffed crust.
- This is so good.
I love that.
- I don't like the cheese
they use in stuffed crust.
- Really?
- Yeah.
It's too thick.
- Yeah,
it's way too thick.
- And it's like,
I feel like it tastes very similar,
so you just get a lot of
cheese, like way too much.
- No, you have to have
the fresh stuffed crust.
Because when starts-
- We'll finish this later.
- When it starts off.
- Staff, please, try.
- Give us your
verdict.
- Staff, give it a go.
- Give us a go.
- We need a second opinion on the show.
- When it starts to harden a bit,
that's when stuff crust.
- [Crew Member] I don't like, what is it?
What is it outside?
- Well, normally, sometimes
it's inside, but I like it.
I think it's good.
I want Sydney's verdict, because American.
- Yeah Sydney, what's your
verdict as an American, Sydney?
- [Sydney] I'll try it,
so do I eat the-
- Why don't you just eat the-
- Just eat it how you normally would,
and then when you get to the crust,
just leave a little bit of the pizza,
and then just go from the side.
- Garnt's like, "Leftover pizza?
Can you believe?"
- Oh, are we doing later?
I died.
I'll finish it later.
- Who just leaves a pizza?
- I'm not that hungry, I'll be honest.
- [Joey] Wanted my American.
- I'm not American, but Goddamn,
sometimes I wish I was.
Maybe that's why I'm so angry
about them all the time,
'cause I just wanna be an American maybe.
(Joey laughing)
I wish I was-
- He's angry at something
he can't be.
- I just, I wish I could be American.
- [Crew Member] It's an
option, I mean, it's fine.
- With dip, it's way better.
- Maybe.
- When you get
some dip on it, man.
- Oh yeah.
- [Crew Member] It's an option.
- If you put some ranch on that shit.
- Oh my God, bro.
It's different.
- Or garlic and herb,
or something.
- It's not stone-baked.
- You can't put ranch on stone-baked.
- [Sydney] No.
- You shouldn't put ranch
on stone-baked, Joey.
- So then what's the verdict?
- I wouldn't dare.
- [Sydney] If I was drunk,
this would be like heaven.
- Yeah, right?
- Yeah.
- [Sydney] But normally,
no, I'd rather cheese in the crust.
- Okay, okay.
I suppose.
- I would
prefer cheese in the crust as well.
- It's like you get a pizza,
and then at the end you're like,
"Oh shit."
- You get like,
a little meal at the end.
- A little hotdog.
- Yeah, yeah.
- All right, okay.
I like, I like it.
I never go to a restaurant
and look a waiter in the eye
and be like,
can I have the option with
the hot dog in the crust?
But, if I can call up a
pizza place and tell them,
"Hey, can you send it with the crust."
For some reason, I feel like-
- I think I've figured out your taste,
which is you need some variety in it.
You can't just have like, even
if something tastes amazing,
you can't just have that same thing.
- Yeah, I mean, I can eat
bread, like straight up.
- Except for bread, apparently.
- Yeah, it's like two
ends of the spectrum.
(Joey laughing)
Either side the no variety,
or too much variety.
- This is where half and half
is amazing as well.
Like, I love half and half.
Who doesn't want half and half?
- I don't want half and half.
- [Joey] I don't like half and half.
- I don't like half and half.
- Why?
Why would you not want
two different flavors?
- Because why not just
order the superior flavor?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And just-
- Well maybe two flavors are amazing,
and I want to experience both.
- One flavor is always the best,
so I order that flavor,
and that's all I need,
because-
- I feel like this is weird.
- I agree.
- Because if you have
half and half-
- Do you never
get half and half?
- Never.
- Very rarely.
- Never by choice.
It's always at a party, right?
Because you need variety
at a party, right?
- Yeah, but I often find that
at halfway through a pizza,
especially heavy one,
I kind of need something
else to kind of mix it up
so that I'm not tasting
just the same, same,
same, same, same.
- But, for me-
- That's what dip is for.
- Yeah, well dip, I mean, I love dip too.
When I have pizza,
I want like every dip on the table,
I'm like, dunk, dunk, dunk.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Well, for me, if I have the same thing,
but it's an amazing same thing,
then I can just eat that endlessly
until I'm full.
- That's true,
because pizza is like,
that style of pizza we
just had is quite heavy.
Like, getting four or
five slices of that in,
you're like, all right.
I need a gingersnap.
- You know what's not?
- Stone-baked.
- Yeah, which they aren't.
Again, I'm not saying
that stone-baked is like,
better.
- It's like
Garnt was waiting for that.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, Garnt's like "Now
is the time to strike."
- That's what he does, right?
If you fold up a stone-baked pizza
into one little ball,
it's like one slice of a normal
American pizza, in depth.
- What?
(Joey laughing)
- Do you fold up your pizza into a ball?
(speakers laughing)
Yo, can we do that?
Can we roll up a stone-baked
pizza into a ball,
and just like, take a bite out of it?
- Just like kind of wrap it around,
so it'll just turn into a dim sum.
- Kind of like a dim sum.
- It's like wove around.
(Garnt laughing)
(Connor laughing)
- I'm like, I'm just
speechless.
- I think I
actually got the Italian
mafia on me for saying that.
- You just lost any rights
to would go to Italy.
- Yeah.
- I think we've all lost some
sort of ride to some sorts of.
I mean, yes you have.
- Yeah.
- Yes, you have.
- You have definitely.
- I'm pretty sure you just
declared war against Italy.
- I'm willing to give credit
where credit's due to Italy,
you know?
- Give credit where
credit is due to Italy.
Like they were the one
that kind of came in,
and was like, "You guys have it good."
- [Connor] Italy's all right.
I mean, a British man says.
(speakers laughing)
Hear me out, right?
(speakers chuckling)
- Hear me out.
- Hear me out,
the Italian's have got
something.
- Coffee,
They're doing that right.
- Yeah.
(Connor laughing)
They got something right, you know.
- Pasta?
They got that on lockdown.
No one can even pretend to
have any claim over pasta.
- Okay, yeah.
So like, okay.
For example, right?
American pasta is like
a little bit different
to the standard Italian pasta, right?
- Italian pasta is fuckin'
drenched in, sorry,
American is fuckin' heavy.
It's so much sauce.
- It's like, oily.
- Like, it's a lot of oil.
- Yeah okay, I don't fuck with that.
That's just too much.
- There is a time and place.
- Yeah.
- Like Imagiano's is like,
every now and then I'll go there
if I wanna feel like I
wanna destroy my stomach.
- Yeah, like I understand how Olive Garden
can do like bottomless stuff.
Like, oh, they do bottomless
bread, don't they?
- Yeah, it's bottomless breadsticks.
- [Connor] Yeah, that's true.
- Which is like, the breadsticks
aren't even that good.
It's like, I don't want bottomless
of something that's mid.
- Would you have an entire
meal of breadsticks?
- It depends how good the breadsticks are.
- If the breadsticks are good?
Not Olive Garden breadsticks though.
- No, no.
- That's just
like bread flavored cardboard.
Sorry Olive Garden, but.
- I'm just wondering-
- When we ordered,
it was Napoleon-style pizza
from around, not too far away.
There's a few chains with of around Tokyo,
and it was awful.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It was really shit.
- [Joey] It wasn't that great.
- It was so bad.
- Yeah.
- Well, I mean it's Japan, right?
- I don't really know, though,
but that was going for like stone-baked,
but not stone-baked.
That was a really weird
hybrid, do you remember that?
- It looked like a stone-baked,
but it didn't taste like it was actually
stone-baked, you know?
It's like, it looks
stone-baked, but here's an oven.
A lot of pizzas I find don't
have a very discernible,
cheesy taste, and I wanna
be able to taste the cheese.
- [Joey] Right.
- I find that like a lot of pizzas either,
because that's also when you put
too much topping on the pizza.
- Yeah.
- Like you can't taste anything,
'cause you just taste meat.
It's too much.
I need to taste all the flavors in unison.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- So like, there needs to
be a right ratio of like,
crust, sauce, and cheese,
and toppings as well.
- Yeah, true, true.
- Otherwise I think there are
some pizzas I see where like,
it's basically just cheesy bread,
and I know that's a type of pizza.
- You can get pizza
that's just cheese, right?
And you could also get margarita.
- Cheese pizza.
- Yeah, which is just a sauce and cheese.
- Yeah.
- I don't understand that.
- I don't fuck with that.
I don't fuck with that.
- [Joey] I get that.
- I guess that's if you're like,
"I wanna have a pizza,
but I don't wanna feel
too bad about it."
- It's like the people who get a pizza,
and then just scrape
the toppings off, right?
- That hurts, that actually hurts.
- I'm like, what happened
to you in your childhood?
- Just get a pasta.
- Sydney does that.
- Oh my God.
- I die a bit inside every time I see
her do that.
- Just dunk your bread
in some pasta sauce.
(Joey giggling)
Just bring like a fuckin' pasta,
like one of those sauce pots with you.
Like, why ruin some pizza?
Like, don't do that.
This is not how I intended
the new year to start,
by the way.
I didn't think I'd be-
- I intended to start this way.
It's not "Trash Taste" without
an argument about food.
- Like, I don't know who had the most
clown opinion this episode.
- You.
- No.
- 90% of bread tastes the same.
- All rice tastes the same?
- Bro, come on.
- Italian pizza in better
than America pizza?
Everyone was a clown today,
ladies and gentlemen.
Everyone was a clown.
- I'm glad we called this "Trash Taste."
It shields us from a lot of criticism.
- Oh, yeah.
- Let's just say that much, because we say
some fucking stupid.
- You can say all you want
guys, but we're "Trash Taste."
What did you expect?
- I like how we made the name
in preparation of us
having shitty anime takes.
None of us intended to ever talk
about food.
- Here's what I hate
about online, right?
Everyone is so scared to give their
genuine opinions on stuff.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like, I'm talking like,
not just like politics and
all that shit, whatever.
I don't give a about fuck about that.
- Like, unimportant stuff.
- Tell me
your weird food tastes that you have
that is really, honestly,
it's quite bizarre, but you'd die by it.
- Everyone has these things.
- Yeah, everyone has
a weird-
- But is scared to tell them.
- Because they were brought
up in a certain way,
or they're not so familiar
with a certain type of cuisine,
or, you know, sometimes taste
buds don't always make sense.
You've got to have,
there's no such thing
as objective taste buds.
- Yeah.
- One of my
favorite dishes as a child,
this is the most British
thing I'm about to say.
- [Joey] Okay.
My mum would just make
mashed potatoes and spam.
Just mashed potato in the spam,
and then just mash it all up,
and just give it to me.
That's it, like the whole plate just that.
- To be fair, it does sound
like it could be good,
but-
- Dude, it's really fucking-
- I don't think I could
eat that repeatedly.
- [Connor] I can.
- Well yeah, of course you can.
- It sounds like something where
if you didn't eat it as a kid,
but you wouldn't like,
you couldn't eat that-
- Maybe we should try it.
- Well, it's like me with natto.
Only reason I like is because
I had it since I was a baby.
- Can you convince kids to like any food?
- Yeah.
I believe you can.
- How did they convince you to like natto,
but they can't convince kids
to like broccoli and stuff?
- Because of the people that
don't like broccoli are babies.
- They are actually babies?
- They're actual babies.
- They're actually babies.
- They're actually...
(Connor chuckles)
How can babies like natto?
- I don't know.
I liked it.
- Maybe, hold on, do you know what it is?
Big brain.
- What?
- Kids love slime.
Kid fuckin' love slime.
Think about it.
- I mean, yeah.
- Think about it.
- Every single YouTube channel
for kids, there's slime.
- I mean, yeah.
- It's all slime.
It's a conspiracy, bro,
I'm getting the red bull.
Bro, that's why kids in Japan,
that's why they love
natto, 'cause it's slime.
- I mean, baby food though.
- I don't know.
- [Joey] Natto is baby
food with beans in it.
- It's slime.
- Look, like.
- It was always the slime.
- It was right
in front of us this whole time.
- [Joey] Right under our nose.
- But like maybe, you know, broccoli or,
what were we talking about, broccoli?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, maybe broccoli
just doesn't taste good
as like, the main
part of the dish.
- No, in the case
with broccoli, isn't
it the fact that like,
because kids' taste
buds are more receptive
to bitter flavors?
As an adult,
and then as you get older.
- Do you like broccoli?
- Yeah, I love broccoli.
- I love broccoli.
I love broccoli.
- Do you like, like broccoli?
- I love broccoli.
You give me like a plate of broccoli,
and I put some mayo on that
shit, and I can just eat it.
- Wait, what?
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah.
- Fuckin', fuckin'...
No.
- Wait, you didn't know broccoli and mayo?
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
That's a very Japanese thing.
- What?
(Joey laughing)
I didn't say it to be controversial.
I thought this was normal.
- You just said that like it was like,
bro, I just like grabbed
the poop out of the toilet.
Just grab it, and I just eat it.
(Connor laughing)
- [Joey] No, it's good.
Try it.
Get some-
- I am down to try this.
- Get some steamed broccoli, right?
Get some Kewpie mayonnaise,
and then dip it.
- Wait, wait,
wait, wait.
- It's very common in Japan.
- Okay, here's why I
recoiled for a moment there.
I had an image of you
with a bowl of broccoli,
and just pouring a bunch of mayo,
but I've ordered from that
chicken and broccoli place,
it's all over Japan.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- It literally gives you, and it's awful,
it's so bad, it's like non-seasoned,
boiled chicken with boiled broccoli.
And it's all prepared,
so they just heat it up
and send it to you, and they
charge you like 30 bucks.
But one of the dips they give you
is low-calorie mayonnaise,
and I got to tell you,
it goes hard.
- Doesn't it?
- Yeah, it actually does.
- It's actually good, like.
- I just realized,
I loved that.
- Yeah.
It's amazing.
- You know what, actually?
Friendship again.
- Yeah, thank you.
Thank you.
- I'm sorry.
- World peace,
world peace.
- Exactly.
- Attained once again.
- I think Garnt's the weird one.
- [Joey] Yeah, he definitely.
Definitely.
- Have you had it?
- Huh?
- We should have it.
- Well no, he doesn't like condiments.
- I will say though.
- Do you hate mayo though?
- Okay I will, no.
- How do you take his opinions seriously?
- Okay, no, I fuckin' hate Mayo, normally.
But, living in Japan, Kewpie mayo, right?
Well, Kewpie mayo fuckin' is amazing.
- Yeah, I know.
- Like,
it's 'cause I've just
had mayo my entire life.
- What do you put it on?
What do you mayo with?
- Sub, whenever it's in a sandwich, right?
- Yeah.
- [Joey] Okay, next time you ever-
- I feel like I'm asking Mark Zuckerberg,
what is being happy?
I ate a sandwich.
- Initiate happy process.
(Joey chuckling)
No, okay.
Next time you have chicken and broccoli,
just get some Kewpie mayo,
and just, don't even
have to drench that shit,
just like a little bit is enough,
because the mayo is already powerful.
You have a flavor, just a little bit.
- Wait, wait, wait,
when you eat a fried chicken,
do you not like it with mayo?
- No, because I like the
taste of fried chicken.
- Whoa.
Mayo's really good at like,
kind of combating the oiliness of it,
and the heaviness of it, somehow.
- That's why a lot-
- And then like,
another oily, heavy liquid.
It somehow kinda mitigates.
- That's why I like with
(indistinct), for example.
You always dip in mayo, right?
- I don't,
just because I like the
taste of fried chicken.
- [Joey] But with the mayo, it's fuckin'.
- This guy knows.
- I don't know.
There are some things
where I said, I just like,
if it's seasoned correctly,
then I enjoy that, right?
Because then I enjoy the
taste of the seasoning,
rather than the taste of the condiment.
- You can't expect like-
- It's like you have some
of the chicken on its own,
and I also have of with the mayo.
- Yeah, just to try it out.
Like, dip it.
- Cleaning the palette,
cleaning the palette.
- Like I've said, if
something tastes fuckin' good,
I can eat that thing
infinitely.
- That's like what
children do, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
(Joey laughing)
- Children, like a dog,
Like a dog, a dog can.
- I used to eat like, spaghetti bolonaise
like five days a week.
Yeah, yeah.
- Sorry my taste buds
actually work, Connor.
- I would argue they don't work,
because you are able to eat the same thing
over and over again.
- If it's good, not if it's bad.
If something tastes good,
then saying you can't eat it
over and over again.
- I have food
that I cannot eat everyday.
- I can't just go back to it.
Like, you know?
- So like, why do you think
it's so easy for me to be like,
I can easily eat the same meal every day.
Right now, I'm eating a
salad every day, and it's-
- Oh, that's fine.
- It's fuckin' easy,
'cause salads taste great.
- Salad is inoffensive.
It's like saying, "Oh, I
can have water every day."
- I do have water every day.
- I do that.
- I have water every day.
- I'm not gonna lie,
I'm not really on board
with that argument.
I'm gonna distance myself
from that argument.
- It's just fuckin salad,
you can't expect the most like,
grandiose combination of flavors,
unless you like drench
that shit in dressing.
- Well, I mean...
I mean,
I don't know.
- Other than that,
it's just like standard vegetables.
- The thing is, I can eat some foods,
okay, I found a salad place,
and I really liked it,
and I ordered that maybe 10 days in a row,
I want to say, I ate the salad.
And then now, for some
reason when I try and eat it,
I know it's really good, but
I just don't like it anymore.
Why is that?
- 'Cause you got bored of it.
- Yeah.
- But isn't that sad.
- Well, that's why you don't
eat the same thing every fuckin' day.
- It was so damn good.
- If it's something that I fucking love,
I purposely try not to eat it often.
- But I think the reason why I went-
- Because there's nothing,
because there's nothing,
because there's nothing
that terrifies me more
than one day sitting in
front of my favorite meal,
having a bite, and going,
"Fuck, it doesn't taste as good as,"-
- I just, the reason why, right?
Here's why, okay?
If it was a pizza, I
wouldn't do it every day.
You know why?
Pizza's are bad for you.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Salads good for you, so I was like,
don't mind if I do, round eight, okay.
And then yeah, I got bored of it,
and now I regret it,
because now I have a harder
time finding healthier food
that I like eating,
so I really fucked myself over.
- That's the real problem,
when you can't have a salad anymore.
- Well, that one type of salad.
- [Joey] That one type of salad.
- 'Cause like, my biggest issue is that
I have to force myself
to have a balanced diet,
because I can easily eat
the same thing every day,
if I really, really enjoy it.
- Yeah.
- Lasagna.
- I could fuck up lasagna.
- World-famous lasagna?
- No, okay, I can eat lasagna every day.
- Yeah, I could eat
lasagna everyday.
- I could fuckin'
eat lasagna everyday.
- Garfield,
Garfield.
- But that's how Garfield.
- I'm not gonna say it's
healthy or balanced,
but I can do it, and
I'm going to enjoy it.
- Of course it's healthy.
- Yeah, of course.
- Of course.
If mom made it, of course it's healthy.
- Papa John's eats a pizza every day.
- He's still alive, somehow.
(speakers laughing)
- He's just the world's
most greasiest human beings.
- Oh my fucking God.
Oh, what a fucking awful episode.
- This is actually been
probably the worst episode
of "Trash Taste" in terms of takes.
- I hope you guys are ready for 2022,
because it might honestly
just get worse from here.
- I feel like I've got
concrete in my stomach.
I don't know what it was from
that have eaten today, but.
- [Joey] It's probably
the fuckin' pizza, right?
- No, no, no.
It couldn't have been that,
that was the best thing I've eaten today.
That was the heaviest slice
of pizza I've had in a while.
- [Connor] It was amazing.
- It was good.
- I should go for another one.
- I can't believe, but that's
a problem in Japan, right?
It tastes good, but you've gotta pay $22
for that entire ass pie.
- Yeah, that's true.
- I know, it sucks.
- It's so offensive.
- Little Caesar's out here
making moves.
- I mean,
it might honestly be a blessing,
because if it costs the
same as an American pizza,
yo I'd be like 500 pounds.
- It's the biggest deterrent, in terms,
you know what we should do, actually?
We should make-
- "Trash Taste" pizza.
- We should make a food three
by three one of these days,
and pick the nine dishes that,
we're gonna defend the nine dishes.
That's going to be like,
the most toxic episode.
- Four-hour "Trash Taste" episode.
- That's gonna be like,
the most toxic episode of "Trash Taste"
that's ever been made.
- [Joey] People skip through that episode.
- We pick the nine dishes
that we couldn't live without.
- You know what format is
really fucking horrible?
But just leads to people
tearing their throats out?
The like, where you put
stuff in a tournament bracket
that shouldn't be in a tournament bracket.
Put like video games in
a tournament bracket,
like the best one goes through.
And it was like, what
was voted the best game?
It was like,
"GTA IV."
- "God of War" right?
- [Connor] "God of War" vs the best game-
- The best game of all time.
- What?
- [Connor] Yeah, IGN's
bracket or something.
We should do that with food.
- Oh I mean,
it's fuckin' IGN.
- We should do a food bracket.
- How long would that take?
- A food tournament-off?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- No, no, no.
Okay, okay.
- We come down, and we have to agree,
what is the best food?
- Okay, okay, okay.
No, I got it, I got it.
- Luckily we're three,
so we're countering.
- Oh yeah, that's true.
- I've got it.
We're gonna make the food three by three,
we're gonna present our favorite foods,
and then we are going to have the bracket
for the viewers to vote for,
and then we're gonna present the winner,
or we're gonna present
the tournament results
on a live stream or something.
That's probably gonna-
- That ball game.
- We're gonna tear each other's
throats out.
- We have to put
more food though, because it'd be like-
- Yeah, that's true.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But we'll figure it out.
- We'll figure it out.
- But look forward to that, I guess.
In the meantime, here are the patrons.
Look at them all.
They love you.
- If they're still here.
(speakers laughing)
- I wouldn't be surprised
if everyone was like, "Yo, this ain't
worth my time."
- Shout out to the Italians
who clocked out an hour and a half ago.
You're the real ones.
- I just wanna imagine what it's like
being an audience member in this episode,
to be like,
"Yeah, he's saying
something that makes sense."
"Oh no."
- I love it when we have
people who are like,
food scientists watching.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like actually, and I'm like,
"Listen, I don't give a fuck."
Tastebuds go brrr, you know what I mean?
Like, I...
- They probably have to do for you.
- I mean, they're all having an aneurysm
in front of the screens
right now.
- I do apologize
for any food experts out there.
I might not be right, but
I'm anecdotally correct,
so that's what matters,
and that's why we were
in a political situation
that no one agrees.
- Yeah.
- You know,
at least, you know,
I may have some clown takes,
but at least I'm friends
with some fellow clowns,
especially this episode.
- Exactly.
- [Joey] This is the circus.
(speakers laughing)
(Joey stuttering)
- This is not "Trash Taste,"
this is the circus now.
- [Joey] This is the circus,
this is a circus.
But hey, if you'd like to join the circus,
then make sure to go to our page on
patreon.com/trashtaste.
- It says a lot about society.
- It says a lot about
the circus, doesn't it?
Also follow us on Twitter,
send it to me in the subreddit,
and you can head there first.
Listen to us on Spotify.
- I think this is the first
time we've literally had
every one of our cast members speak out
against something we've
once individually said.
- Before we wrap this up,
where the fuck is Grindlewald?
Where's Grindlewald?
- What?
Oh.
- Why isn't he on the shelves, bro?
- I don't know.
- The best figure from
the whole purchasing.
- He's in the corner.
Somewhere.
- I didn't-
- Bring him out, bring him out.
Give him here, give him right to Connor.
Let's put them on the table.
There we go.
Leave him right there.
- Oh, heck yeah.
- I thought you were talking
about the Majora's mask.
I was like, wait, does...
- [Joey] Does that not have a name?
- Is his name Grindlewald?
- Joey, tell him to fuck off.
- All right.
Fuck off.
Bye.
(speakers laughing)
- [Garnt] Bye.
(relaxing music)